Hey everybody, we are here with part two of the Origins of the Internet with John Day. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. We are here with part two of the origins of the internet with John Day. And thanks so much, John, for coming back. And I still have a ton of content to go through. So I really appreciate you taking time out of your day to do a second round here. Thanks so much. My pleasure. My pleasure. Cool. I felt like we should kick it off with the sort of elephant in the room, which is IPv6, right? I remember, you know,
Hey everybody, we are here with part two of the Origins of the Internet with John Day. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. We are here with part two of the origins of the internet with John Day. And thanks so much, John, for coming back. And I still have a ton of content to go through. So I really appreciate you taking time out of your day to do a second round here. Thanks so much. My pleasure. My pleasure. Cool. I felt like we should kick it off with the sort of elephant in the room, which is IPv6, right? I remember, you know,|||大家好，我们今天和约翰·戴（John Day）一起进行“互联网起源”的第二部分。请开始吧，Jason。大家好。我们和约翰·戴一起进行互联网起源的第二部分。非常感谢约翰再次来到这里。我还有大量的干货要聊，所以我非常感谢你抽出时间来做第二轮节目。非常感谢。我的荣幸。我的荣幸。太好了。我觉得我们应该从一个显而易见但又难以忽视的问题开始，那就是IPv6，对吧？我记得，你知道的，
I've done a lot of peer-to-peer networking things in the past. And, you know, I remember seeing IPv6, I don't even know how many years ago. I mean, definitely more than a decade ago. And saying, this is amazing, because, you know, all the NAT traversal and NAT punch through and all these tricks you have to do where two computers send packets to a third computer, and it sort of like connects them to
I've done a lot of peer-to-peer networking things in the past. And, you know, I remember seeing IPv6, I don't even know how many years ago. I mean, definitely more than a decade ago. And saying, this is amazing, because, you know, all the NAT traversal and NAT punch through and all these tricks you have to do where two computers send packets to a third computer, and it sort of like connects them to|||我过去做过很多P2P网络的事情。而且，你知道，我记得看到IPv6时，我甚至不知道是多少年前了。我的意思是，绝对超过十年了。当时我就说，这太厉害了，因为，你知道，所有的NAT遍历、NAT打洞以及你必须做的那些把戏——比如两台计算机向第三台计算机发送数据包，然后它把它们连接在一起——
each other. Like all of these things that, you know, aren't guaranteed to work would fade away. And I'd be able to say, here's the IP address of your refrigerator. I'd just like go and send it a packet. None of that came true. And so I think it'd be good to start with just what the heck happened? Like what is IPv6? What was it supposed to do? What really happened there? First of all, whenever anyone's talking about, I want to have my refrigerator on the internet, my response has always been no bloody way in hell yeah right yeah you know i mean i want something between me and the rest of the world yeah exactly refrigerator in the rest of the world but anyway in the late 80s early 90s for some reason which i do not understand to this day, they were handing out, well, there were two problems going on.
each other. Like all of these things that, you know, aren't guaranteed to work would fade away. And I'd be able to say, here's the IP address of your refrigerator. I'd just like go and send it a packet. None of that came true. And so I think it'd be good to start with just what the heck happened? Like what is IPv6? What was it supposed to do? What really happened there? First of all, whenever anyone's talking about, I want to have my refrigerator on the internet, my response has always been no bloody way in hell yeah right yeah you know i mean i want something between me and the rest of the world yeah exactly refrigerator in the rest of the world but anyway in the late 80s early 90s for some reason which i do not understand to this day, they were handing out, well, there were two problems going on.|||就像所有这些你知道的无法保证百分之百成功的东西都会消失。我就可以说，这是你冰箱的IP地址。我直接去给它发个包就行了。这些都没有成为现实。所以我觉得最好还是从“到底发生了什么鬼”开始聊起？比如什么是IPv6？它本来应该做什么？那里到底发生了什么？首先，每当有人说“我想把我的冰箱连上互联网”时，我的反应一直是：门都没有，休想，绝对不可能，是吧，你知道的，我的意思是，我希望我和世界其他地方之间有某种隔离，对吧，没错，冰箱和世界其他地方也是如此。但不管怎样，在80年代末90年代初，由于某种我至今无法理解的原因，他们在分发……好吧，当时有两个问题正在发生。
One, we were being very free with handing out IP addresses. And so they were able to see that we were going to come to the end of 2 to the 32 at some point. That was the minor problem. The big problem was that they had been handing out addresses in order, blocks of addresses in order, which would never have occurred to me. I mean, I'm a flatlander. I know about addresses. You know, I mean, you know, they tell you how to get there. Well, they don't tell you. They tell you where something is and you can figure out from that how to get there. You know, so in prior to 1990 or so, if you got a block of addresses, if say you're in Paris and you ask for a block of IP addresses, you've got block X.
One, we were being very free with handing out IP addresses. And so they were able to see that we were going to come to the end of 2 to the 32 at some point. That was the minor problem. The big problem was that they had been handing out addresses in order, blocks of addresses in order, which would never have occurred to me. I mean, I'm a flatlander. I know about addresses. You know, I mean, you know, they tell you how to get there. Well, they don't tell you. They tell you where something is and you can figure out from that how to get there. You know, so in prior to 1990 or so, if you got a block of addresses, if say you're in Paris and you ask for a block of IP addresses, you've got block X.|||第一，我们当时在分发IP地址时非常随意。因此他们能够预见到，我们在某个时刻将会用完2的32次方个地址。这是个小问题。大问题是，他们一直在按顺序分发地址，按顺序分发地址块，这我怎么也想不到。我的意思是，我是个平原人（注：指常规思维的人），我懂地址是怎么回事。你知道，我的意思是，你知道，地址会告诉你怎么去那里。好吧，它们并没有直接告诉你怎么走。它们告诉你某物在哪里，你可以从中学到如何到达那里。你知道的，所以在1990年左右之前，如果你得到了一块地址，比如说你在巴黎，你申请了一块IP地址，你得到了X块。
If the next person to ask was from Sri Lanka, they got X plus one. Wait, wait, wait, really? Yes. Wait, I thought that isn't there. I thought I've seen a map, right, which has IP addresses and like some, isn't there like a regional thing there? You young guys just don't. No, no, no. So consequently, every time a block of addresses was assigned, it had to have an entry in the router table.
If the next person to ask was from Sri Lanka, they got X plus one. Wait, wait, wait, really? Yes. Wait, I thought that isn't there. I thought I've seen a map, right, which has IP addresses and like some, isn't there like a regional thing there? You young guys just don't. No, no, no. So consequently, every time a block of addresses was assigned, it had to have an entry in the router table.|||如果下一个申请的人来自斯里兰卡，他们得到的Adresse就是X加一。等等，等等，真的吗？是的。等等，我以为不是这样的。我以为我见过一张地图，上面有IP地址和一些……难道那里没有什么区域性的东西吗？你们这些年轻人才不……不，不，不。因此，每分配一个地址块，路由表中就必须有一个条目。
And the router table size was going through the roof exponentially. Ah, okay. Right? And so to me, prior to CIDR, Classless Inter-Domain Routing, IP addresses weren't really addresses. Oh, interesting. Okay. I mean, not in the sense of, you know, 1600, you know, Pennsylvania Avenue. Tells you where it is.
And the router table size was going through the roof exponentially. Ah, okay. Right? And so to me, prior to CIDR, Classless Inter-Domain Routing, IP addresses weren't really addresses. Oh, interesting. Okay. I mean, not in the sense of, you know, 1600, you know, Pennsylvania Avenue. Tells you where it is.|||而且路由表的大小呈指数级飙升。啊，原来如此。对吧？所以对我来说，在CIDR（无类别域间路由）出现之前，IP地址其实并不是真正的地址。哦，真有趣。好吧。我的意思是，不是那种像宾夕法尼亚大道1600号那样的意义上的地址。能告诉你它在哪里。
Yeah. Right? No, no, no. So that was scaring the heck out of them. And so the IAB convened a process to figure out what was going on. So real quick, what is the IAB? Oh, I'm sorry. The Internet Architecture Board.
Yeah. Right? No, no, no. So that was scaring the heck out of them. And so the IAB convened a process to figure out what was going on. So real quick, what is the IAB? Oh, I'm sorry. The Internet Architecture Board.|||对吧？不，不，不。所以这把他们吓得半死。于是IAB召开了一个程序来弄清楚到底是怎么回事。那么简单问一下，什么是IAB？哦，对不起。互联网架构委员会（Internet Architecture Board）。
Okay. Got it. It was called the ROAD process. And I forget what that acronym is. Routing, something or other. Anyway, of course, the OSI stuff is going on in parallel with this stuff. Now, we had a longstanding problem with IP addresses to begin with because they named the interface, just like the ARPANET IMPs did, right? And to solve the multi-homing problem, you need to name the route to the node. Right, right. Okay. So OSI, having been working on this earlier, had solved this problem. A network address in OSI named the node. And so what is OSI again? Open seven-layer model.
Okay. Got it. It was called the ROAD process. And I forget what that acronym is. Routing, something or other. Anyway, of course, the OSI stuff is going on in parallel with this stuff. Now, we had a longstanding problem with IP addresses to begin with because they named the interface, just like the ARPANET IMPs did, right? And to solve the multi-homing problem, you need to name the route to the node. Right, right. Okay. So OSI, having been working on this earlier, had solved this problem. A network address in OSI named the node. And so what is OSI again? Open seven-layer model.|||好的。明白了。这被称为ROAD进程。我忘了那个缩写是什么了。路由，什么什么的。不管怎样，当然，OSI的相关工作是与此并行进行的。现在，我们一开始就有一个长期存在的IP地址问题，因为它们命名的是接口，就像阿帕网（ARPANET）的IMP所做的那样，对吧？为了解决多归属（multi-homing）问题，你需要命名通往节点的路由。对，对，好的。所以OSI在这个问题上起步更早，已经解决了这个问题。OSI中的网络地址命名的是节点。那么OSI又是什么？开放式七层模型。
Open seven-layer model. No, no, no. Open systems interconnection. Oh, oh, got it. Okay, got it. Right, the seven-layer model. And so just for people, and I'm not going to get this right, but one of the layers is IP, one is TCP. What are the seven layers?
Open seven-layer model. No, no, no. Open systems interconnection. Oh, oh, got it. Okay, got it. Right, the seven-layer model. And so just for people, and I'm not going to get this right, but one of the layers is IP, one is TCP. What are the seven layers?|||开放式七层模型。不，不，不。开放系统互连（Open systems interconnection）。哦，哦，明白了。好的，明白了。对，七层模型。为了让大家了解——虽然我可能说不准——其中一层是IP，一层是TCP。那七层都是什么？
I used to know, but I totally forgot. Physical, data link, network, transport, session, presentation, application. Ah, okay. Got it. However, backing up a little bit, after 1983, we realized the upper three layers were a single layer. Yep, that makes sense. Okay. We also realized by the mid-'80s that the network layer was actually three pieces, three sublayers.
I used to know, but I totally forgot. Physical, data link, network, transport, session, presentation, application. Ah, okay. Got it. However, backing up a little bit, after 1983, we realized the upper three layers were a single layer. Yep, that makes sense. Okay. We also realized by the mid-'80s that the network layer was actually three pieces, three sublayers.|||我以前知道，但全忘了。物理层、数据链路层、网络层、传输层、会话层、表示层、应用层。啊，好吧。明白了。不过，退一步讲，在1983年之后，我们意识到上面三层其实是一个单层。是的，这说得通。好的。到80年代中期，我们也意识到网络层实际上由三部分、三个子层组成。
Okay. What it was was, in this sense, OSI didn't lose a layer. Okay. The bottom two roles of the network layer were the network. The upper part was the internet layer. Got it. Okay. Now, so anyway, the ITF has this problem with IP.
Okay. What it was was, in this sense, OSI didn't lose a layer. Okay. The bottom two roles of the network layer were the network. The upper part was the internet layer. Got it. Okay. Now, so anyway, the ITF has this problem with IP.|||好的。也就是说，从这个意义上讲，OSI并没有丢掉一层。好吧。网络层的底下两个角色构成了网络。上面部分是互联网层。明白了。好吧。总之，IETF在IP方面遇到了这个问题。
This is going to be a chance to fix the Mully-Homing problem. Also, we'll have to have bigger addresses. And we're going to have to start assigning addresses so that they aggregate, so that they're really addresses. Right. So if you see like the first few octets, you kind of know roughly where it's going to be in the world. Right, right. Relative to the big graph of the networks of the world, where it is. And of course, CIDR was the first step in that.
This is going to be a chance to fix the Mully-Homing problem. Also, we'll have to have bigger addresses. And we're going to have to start assigning addresses so that they aggregate, so that they're really addresses. Right. So if you see like the first few octets, you kind of know roughly where it's going to be in the world. Right, right. Relative to the big graph of the networks of the world, where it is. And of course, CIDR was the first step in that.|||这将是一个解决多归属（Multi-Homing）问题的机会。此外，我们必须拥有更大的地址。我们必须开始分配地址，使它们能够聚合，使它们真正成为地址。对的。所以如果你看到前几个字节，你大概就知道它在全球什么位置了。对，对。相对于全球网络的大图景，它在哪里。当然，CIDR是其中的第一步。
The second step was instead of going to IANA to get your addresses, if you were a small guy, they started giving huge blocks of addresses to tier one providers. OK, and then you went to your tier one provider to get an address. That way, you know, we knew by looking at the, at the beginning of the address that it belonged to Verizon. Okay. Got it. So, so Verizon would own, um, I think it's called class B or something like that where they own class a, a class A. They own class A. So they own like 13 dot anything else. Well, right. But now the other thing was that in the original IP addresses, as you said, there were class A, class B, class C addresses.
The second step was instead of going to IANA to get your addresses, if you were a small guy, they started giving huge blocks of addresses to tier one providers. OK, and then you went to your tier one provider to get an address. That way, you know, we knew by looking at the, at the beginning of the address that it belonged to Verizon. Okay. Got it. So, so Verizon would own, um, I think it's called class B or something like that where they own class a, a class A. They own class A. So they own like 13 dot anything else. Well, right. But now the other thing was that in the original IP addresses, as you said, there were class A, class B, class C addresses.|||第二步是，如果你是个小玩家，你不用去找IANA获取地址，他们开始把巨额的地址块分配给一级（tier one）运营商。好的，然后你去找你的一级运营商获取地址。这样一来，你知道的，我们通过看地址的开头就知道它属于威瑞森（Verizon）。好的。明白了。所以，威瑞森将拥有，嗯，我记得这叫B类还是别的什么，他们拥有A类，A类。他们拥有A类。所以他们拥有类似13点开头的一切。嗯，对。但现在另一件事是，在最初的IP地址中，正如你所说，有A类、B类、C类的地址。
And this put a boundary between the network part and the host part. There were essentially 256 class A's. Then the class A's. Then the class B's were halfway. So there was 16 bits of network and 16 bits of O's. And then class C's were 24 bits and 8 bits of O's. CIDR, classless interlomain routing, allowed that to be, that boundary to be moved anywhere. So you'll hear people talk about it's a slash 16 or a slash 24, something like that.
And this put a boundary between the network part and the host part. There were essentially 256 class A's. Then the class A's. Then the class B's were halfway. So there was 16 bits of network and 16 bits of O's. And then class C's were 24 bits and 8 bits of O's. CIDR, classless interlomain routing, allowed that to be, that boundary to be moved anywhere. So you'll hear people talk about it's a slash 16 or a slash 24, something like that.|||这在网络部分和主机部分之间设定了一条界限。基本上有256个A类地址。然后是A类。接着B类在中间。所以有16位网络位和16位主机位。然后C类是24位网络位和8位主机位。CIDR（无类别域间路由）允许将该界限移动到任何地方。所以你会听到人们谈论它是斜杠16（/16）还是斜杠24（/24）之类的东西。
Okay. That would define the mask that you would end with the address to get the part you were supposed to route on. Now, that was the first step. Clearly, clearly, we're going to have to have bigger addresses, so we have to have a new protocol. There was a lot of debate around it. There was this group that went to, you know, and the group decided to emphasize running out of addresses because they thought everyone could understand that. But rather than we're running out of router table size or router table size is becoming a problem. And I mean, at that point, it was like 200,000 routes in the core routers and climbing. It's now over half a million. some debate um osi had developed a protocol called clmp connectionalist network protocol
Okay. That would define the mask that you would end with the address to get the part you were supposed to route on. Now, that was the first step. Clearly, clearly, we're going to have to have bigger addresses, so we have to have a new protocol. There was a lot of debate around it. There was this group that went to, you know, and the group decided to emphasize running out of addresses because they thought everyone could understand that. But rather than we're running out of router table size or router table size is becoming a problem. And I mean, at that point, it was like 200,000 routes in the core routers and climbing. It's now over half a million. some debate um osi had developed a protocol called clmp connectionalist network protocol|||好的。这将定义你最终与地址进行与（AND）运算的掩码，以获得你应该用来路由的部分。这是第一步。显然，很显然，我们必须拥有更大的地址，所以我们必须有一个新协议。这周围有很多争论。有这样一个团体去了，你知道的，这个团体决定强调“地址快用完了”，因为他们认为每个人都能理解这一点。而不是强调“我们的路由表大小快用完了”或者“路由表大小正在成为一个问题”。我的意思是，当时核心路由器中的路由大约有20万条，而且还在不断攀升。现在已经超过50万条了。有一些争论，嗯，OSI曾开发过一种名为CLMP（无连接网络协议）的协议——
that was a variable length address that could be much larger i think it was like 40 octets or something and but was basically you know just like ip except that it named the node well can you dive into that a little bit so So if the node has multiple NICs and the IP address names the node, then I guess, let's just take a simple example. So a packet hits my home router. And I actually have this. I have a wireless and a wired connection into my desktop.
that was a variable length address that could be much larger i think it was like 40 octets or something and but was basically you know just like ip except that it named the node well can you dive into that a little bit so So if the node has multiple NICs and the IP address names the node, then I guess, let's just take a simple example. So a packet hits my home router. And I actually have this. I have a wireless and a wired connection into my desktop.|||那是一种可变长度的地址，可以大得多，我想大概是40个八位组（octets）左右，但基本上，你知道，就像IP一样，只是它命名的是节点。那么，你能稍微深入讲讲这个吗？所以，如果节点有多个网卡（NIC），而IP地址命名的是节点，那么我猜，让我们举个简单的例子。假设一个数据包到达我的家用路由器。我实际上就有这种情况。我的台式机同时有无线和有线连接。
I have the wireless one turned off, probably because it doesn't play nicely for the reasons we talked about but let's say i had that on right so then the router would um because it names a node the router would have to basically decide on the fly which neck to send it well no wait okay think about this if the wire coming into the nick is point to point with another router. It doesn't need an IP address. There's no place else for it to go. It gets sent from the other router. There's only one place for it to come out.
I have the wireless one turned off, probably because it doesn't play nicely for the reasons we talked about but let's say i had that on right so then the router would um because it names a node the router would have to basically decide on the fly which neck to send it well no wait okay think about this if the wire coming into the nick is point to point with another router. It doesn't need an IP address. There's no place else for it to go. It gets sent from the other router. There's only one place for it to come out.|||我把无线连接关掉了，可能是因为它由于我们讨论过的原因表现得不太好。但假设我把它打开了，对吧？那么路由器就会……嗯，因为它是按节点命名的，路由器基本上必须现场决定将它发到哪个网卡上。不，等等，好吧，想想看：如果进入网卡的电线是与另一个路由器的点对点连接，它不需要IP地址。它无处可去。它是从另一个路由器发送过来的。它只有一个出口。
Okay. Now, you have multiple wires running into your router. Okay, fine. But all I need for that is a local identifier to distinguish them. I don't need addresses. A local. So what's the difference? Well, I'm not taking up IP address local. So what's the difference? Well,
Okay. Now, you have multiple wires running into your router. Okay, fine. But all I need for that is a local identifier to distinguish them. I don't need addresses. A local. So what's the difference? Well, I'm not taking up IP address local. So what's the difference? Well,|||好的。现在，有多条电线连接到你的路由器。好吧，行。但这只需要一个本地标识符来区分它们。我不需要地址。一个本地标识符。那么有什么区别呢？好吧，我没有占用本地的IP地址空间。那么有什么区别呢？好吧，
I'm not taking up IP address space. But then, okay, so let's say someone sends a packet to this address. Then at some point, someone has to decide which network card to send it to, right? Yeah. And he decides. No, he doesn't decide. Okay. No. He decides which outgoing interface of his he puts it on. Right, right, right. He doesn't decide anything about your network, your NIC card. Okay, yeah, that's fair. But implicitly, it's the same thing. Well, no, it's not.
I'm not taking up IP address space. But then, okay, so let's say someone sends a packet to this address. Then at some point, someone has to decide which network card to send it to, right? Yeah. And he decides. No, he doesn't decide. Okay. No. He decides which outgoing interface of his he puts it on. Right, right, right. He doesn't decide anything about your network, your NIC card. Okay, yeah, that's fair. But implicitly, it's the same thing. Well, no, it's not.|||我没有占用IP地址空间。但是，好吧，假设有人向这个地址发送了一个数据包。然后在某个时刻，总得有人决定把它发送到哪个网卡，对吧？是的。而他决定了。不，他没有决定。好吧。不。他决定的是把它放在他自己的哪一个出接口上。对，对，对。他并不决定你的网络或网卡上的任何事情。好吧，是的，这倒也是。但从隐含意义上讲，这是一回事。嗯，不，并不是。
Well, so my router could send a packet over the Ethernet. Now you need an address on it because there are multiple things that will see it. Oh, I see what you're saying. Okay. Yeah, I got it. This is where having a picture would help. Yeah, I know. It makes sense. That address is called the point of attachment address.
Well, so my router could send a packet over the Ethernet. Now you need an address on it because there are multiple things that will see it. Oh, I see what you're saying. Okay. Yeah, I got it. This is where having a picture would help. Yeah, I know. It makes sense. That address is called the point of attachment address.|||嗯，所以我的路由器可以通过以太网发送数据包。现在你需要在它上面附加一个地址，因为有多个东西会看到它。哦，我明白你的意思了。好吧。是的，我懂了。这时候有张图就好了。是的，我知道。这说得通。那个地址被称为接入点（point of attachment）地址。
Okay. Got it. You can have multiple points of attachment addresses, but they all go to one node address. Right. Right. Okay. And where you're trying to get to is the node. Right. Right. One of the things, and I've got a slide like this. One of the things I think people make a big mistake, you know, all those little disk router diagrams everybody draws? Yeah. Okay. Well, everybody thinks that when the wire hits the little disk thing, that that's the end. It's not because those all have to go up to the node, which decides whether
Okay. Got it. You can have multiple points of attachment addresses, but they all go to one node address. Right. Right. Okay. And where you're trying to get to is the node. Right. Right. One of the things, and I've got a slide like this. One of the things I think people make a big mistake, you know, all those little disk router diagrams everybody draws? Yeah. Okay. Well, everybody thinks that when the wire hits the little disk thing, that that's the end. It's not because those all have to go up to the node, which decides whether|||好的。明白了。你可以有多个接入点地址，但它们都指向同一个节点地址。对。对。好的。而你试图到达的目标是那个节点。对。对。其中有一点，我有一张这样的幻灯片。我认为人们常犯的一个重大错误是——你知道大家画的所有那些小圆盘路由器图吗？是的。好的。好吧，每个人都认为当电缆连接到那个小圆盘东西时，那就是终点。其实并不是，因为这些都必须向上传输到节点，由节点来决定——
or not this is for me or not. Right. Right. Okay. I mean, I was, you know, there's always been a debate, you know, and everyone was always, you know, sort of like, well, what does the IP address or any address really name? And as I was telling one of the old sages some time ago, my definition came down to it names whatever strips the address off. Yeah, right. Okay. So the problem here is that IP addresses name interfaces.
or not this is for me or not. Right. Right. Okay. I mean, I was, you know, there's always been a debate, you know, and everyone was always, you know, sort of like, well, what does the IP address or any address really name? And as I was telling one of the old sages some time ago, my definition came down to it names whatever strips the address off. Yeah, right. Okay. So the problem here is that IP addresses name interfaces.|||这到底是不是给我的。对。对。好吧。我的意思是，我当时……你知道，一直存在着一场争论，你知道，每个人总是觉得，嗯，IP地址或任何地址到底命名了什么？正如我不久前对一位老前辈所说的那样，我的定义归结为：它命名的是任何剥离该地址的实体。是的，没错。好吧。所以这里的问题是，IP地址命名的是接口。
They're point of attachment addresses. Got it. Just like ARPANET addresses were. And so the IPv6 fixes, or not fixes, but it addresses the large number. We're not there yet. So coming out of the road process, they recommend the adoption of IPv7, which is CLMP. I never even heard of that. Is that a new thing?
They're point of attachment addresses. Got it. Just like ARPANET addresses were. And so the IPv6 fixes, or not fixes, but it addresses the large number. We're not there yet. So coming out of the road process, they recommend the adoption of IPv7, which is CLMP. I never even heard of that. Is that a new thing?|||它们是接入点地址。明白了。就像阿帕网地址一样。所以IPv6修复了——或者说不是修复，而是解决了数量庞大的问题。我们还没到那一步。因此，从ROAD进程中出来后，他们建议采用IPv7，也就是CLMP。我甚至没听说过那个。那是新东西吗？
When did that come out? The internet, the IETF goes berserk. And I mean berserk. Okay. Well, what's the timeframe on this? Like when did, when was this happening? 1990, 1991. Okay.
When did that come out? The internet, the IETF goes berserk. And I mean berserk. Okay. Well, what's the timeframe on this? Like when did, when was this happening? 1990, 1991. Okay.|||它是什么时候出来的？互联网，IETF气疯了。我是说彻底抓狂了。好吧。那这的时间线是怎样的？比如是什么时候，这发生在什么时候？1990年，1991年。好的。
And so IPv6 had already been. No, no. IPv6 has not come up yet. Oh, so seven is before six. Yeah. Okay. Got it. Okay.
And so IPv6 had already been. No, no. IPv6 has not come up yet. Oh, so seven is before six. Yeah. Okay. Got it. Okay.|||所以IPv6当时已经……不，不。IPv6当时还没出现呢。哦，所以七在六前面。对。好吧。明白了。好的。
And because it was this came from OSI and seven layers. Ah, okay. Okay. They go berserk. Friend of mine was the chair of the IAB at the time. He was getting 70 nasty emails an hour. An hour. Okay. Oh my God. 24 hours a day, seven days a week. Wow. Okay. How he survived, I'll never know. Okay. There was this huge hue and cry. They're not going to do anything that comes from OSI. So some people in high places backed off from this proposal. There was an IPNG process, you know, IP next generation, a huge debate. And I mean, this was a nasty,
And because it was this came from OSI and seven layers. Ah, okay. Okay. They go berserk. Friend of mine was the chair of the IAB at the time. He was getting 70 nasty emails an hour. An hour. Okay. Oh my God. 24 hours a day, seven days a week. Wow. Okay. How he survived, I'll never know. Okay. There was this huge hue and cry. They're not going to do anything that comes from OSI. So some people in high places backed off from this proposal. There was an IPNG process, you know, IP next generation, a huge debate. And I mean, this was a nasty,|||而且因为这是来自OSI和七层模型的。啊，好吧。好的。他们气炸了。我的一个朋友当时是IAB的主席。他每小时收到70封恶意的电子邮件。每小时。好的。天哪。每周七天，每天24小时。哇。好吧。他是怎么活下来的，我永远也不会知道。好吧。当时有巨大的抗议声和反对声。他们绝不做任何源自OSI的东西。所以高层的一些人从这个提议中退缩了。后来有了一个IPNG进程，你知道的，IP下一代（IP next generation），引发了巨大的争论。我的意思是，这是一场极其恶劣的、
nasty debate. I've seen worse, but not many. And finally out of it comes IPv6. Now, one of the other big deals about in the debate was the debate. There were two things. One was a variable length address versus a fixed length address. Oh, interesting. And some people didn't understand about scatter gather hardware. So they were just adamant that you couldn't do it fast with a variable length address. Turns out you can. But, you know, they won out. So we have a fixed length address. It continues to name the interface. They were not going to do anything OSI had done. They're now cutting off their nose to spite their face. So we get IPv6. Two weeks after IPv6 was approved, someone points out that IPv6 doesn't do anything for the guy who has to adopt it.
nasty debate. I've seen worse, but not many. And finally out of it comes IPv6. Now, one of the other big deals about in the debate was the debate. There were two things. One was a variable length address versus a fixed length address. Oh, interesting. And some people didn't understand about scatter gather hardware. So they were just adamant that you couldn't do it fast with a variable length address. Turns out you can. But, you6 (v6) won out. So we have a fixed length address. It continues to name the interface. They were not going to do anything OSI had done. They're now cutting off their nose to spite their face. So we get IPv6. Two weeks after IPv6 was approved, someone points out that IPv6 doesn't do anything for the guy who has to adopt it.|||恶劣的争论。我见过更糟的，但也沒几个。最后，IPv6从中诞生了。现在，辩论中的另一个大问题是……当时有两件事。一个是可变长度地址与固定长度地址的对比。哦，有意思。有些人对散布-聚集（scatter-gather）硬件不了解。所以他们坚信，使用可变长度地址无法做到高速处理。事实证明是可以的。但是，v6获胜了。所以我们有了一个固定长度的地址。它继续命名接口。他们坚决不做任何OSI做过的事情。他们现在这是因小失大、割鼻求荣。所以我们得到了IPv6。在IPv6获胜（批准）两周后，有人指出，IPv6对于那些必须采用它的人来说，根本没有任何实质帮助。
What does that mean? Do you elaborate on that? Well, okay. So I go to my upper management and I say, I'd like to spend $3 million converting our company to IPv6. And upper management says, oh, well, great. I mean, I assume this makes our network more efficient. This has been a bottom line, all this. And the guy says, well, it makes us a better network citizen.
What does that mean? Do you elaborate on that? Well, okay. So I go to my upper management and I say, I'd like to spend $3 million converting our company to IPv6. And upper management says, oh, well, great. I mean, I assume this makes our network more efficient. This has been a bottom line, all this. And the guy says, well, it makes us a better network citizen.|||这是什么意思？你能详细说说吗？嗯，好吧。所以，我去找我的高层管理人员说，我想花300万美元把我们公司的网络转换为IPv6。高层管理人员说，哦，那太好了。我的意思是，我假设这会让我们的网络更高效。这一直是底线，诸如此类。然后这家伙说，嗯，这能让我们成为一个更好的网络公民。
Yeah, right, right. It's a tragedy of the commons. Well, no, I mean, in fact, it doesn't fix anything. In fact, when the IPv6 committee first convened, the only thing problem they thought they had was a bigger address. They didn't understand the router table problem. It's okay. Now, if you had fixed the multi-homing problem, okay, with CLMP, you could then do mobility with nothing new. And what is CLMP one more time? IPv7. Oh, right. Okay.
Yeah, right, right. It's a tragedy of the commons. Well, no, I mean, in fact, it doesn't fix anything. In fact, when the IPv6 committee first convened, the only thing problem they thought they had was a bigger address. They didn't understand the router table problem. It's okay. Now, if you had fixed the multi-homing problem, okay, with CLMP, you could then do mobility with nothing new. And what is CLMP one more time? IPv7. Oh, right. Okay.|||对，没错，没错。这就是公地悲剧。嗯，不，我的意思是，事实上，它什么也没解决。事实上，当IPv6委员会首次开会时，他们认为自己唯一的麻烦就是需要更大的地址。他们根本不懂路由表的问题。没关系。现在，如果你通过CLMP解决了多归属（multi-homing）问题，你就可以在不需要任何新东西的情况下实现移动性。CLMP到底是什么？IPv7。哦，对。好的。
Got it. Okay. So, you know, basically the reason IPv6 has been around for so long and nobody doing anything with it was why? There's no incentive for any one person to adopt it. No reason to do it. Okay. You know, what's the big deal?
Got it. So, you know, basically the reason IPv6 has been around for so long and nobody doing anything with it was why? There's no incentive for any one person to adopt it. No reason to do it. Okay. You know, what's the big deal?|||明白了。所以，你知道，基本上IPv6存在了这么久却没有人去理会它的原因是什么？因为对任何个人来说，都没有动力去采用它。没有理由去做这件事。好吧。你知道，这有什么大不了的？
And they haven't exactly made it easy. A friend of mine did a, I mean, you know, you used to hear all of the, you know, it's better security and better quality of service and better this and better that. Or as Mike O'Dell says, you know, it's a dessert topping and a four wax. You know? It's a dessert topping and a floor wax. I remember there probably still is an IPv6 day where everyone's encouraged to use IPv6. I only participated one year. I tried to use IPv6. I think you have to ask your ISP.
And they haven't exactly made it easy. A friend of mine did a, I mean, you know, you used to hear all of the, you know, it's better security and better quality of service and better this and better that. Or as Mike O'Dell says, you know, it's a dessert topping and a four wax. You know? It's a dessert topping and a floor wax. I remember there probably still is an IPv6 day where everyone's encouraged to use IPv6. I only participated one year. I tried to use IPv6. I think you have to ask your ISP.|||而且他们也确实没有让它变得更容易。我的一个朋友做过一个……我的意思是，你知道的，你过去常常听到各种说法，比如它有更好的安全性、更好的服务质量、更好的这个和那个。或者正如迈克·奥德尔（Mike O'Dell）所说，你知道的，它既是甜点顶料又是地板蜡。你知道吗？它既是甜点顶料又是地板蜡。我记得可能仍然有一个“IPv6日”，鼓励大家使用IPv6。我只参加过一年。我尝试过使用IPv6。我想你得去问你的ISP（互联网服务提供商）。
I don't even remember, but I remember just giving up pretty early. Well, as I said, they thought the only problem they had was bigger addresses. They didn't understand the router table size problem. There's a friend of mine who's done a YouTube thing called the myths of IPv6. All of the stuff about better security, better this, better that, were all spin. It was all the same as v4. In fact, one of the ground rules when they passed v6 was that anything they did had to be worked with v4
I don't even remember, but I remember just giving up pretty early. Well, as I said, they thought the only problem they had was bigger addresses. They didn't understand the router table size problem. There's a friend of mine who's done a YouTube thing called the myths of IPv6. All of the stuff about better security, better this, better that, were all spin. It was all the same as v4. In fact, one of the ground rules when they passed v6 was that anything they did had to be worked with v4|||我甚至记不清了，但我记得很早就放弃了。嗯，正如我所说，他们认为自己唯一的麻烦就是更大的地址。他们根本不理解路由表大小的问题。我的一个朋友在YouTube上做过一个名为《IPv6的神话》的视频。所有关于更好的安全性、更好的这个、更好的那个的说法，全都是宣传噱头。它和v4完全一样。事实上，他们通过v6时的基本原则之一是，他们做的任何事情都必须能够与v4协同工作——
in case they had to back it out. There was that much confidence in v6. Right, right. Okay. And they made silly mistakes. i don't i still i haven't figured found out i haven't bothered to look to see how they fixed it but they got rid of the protocol id field in v6 by saying it's the last option now the protocol id field tells you what protocol is encapsulated in ip and there's a registry for it at IANA with numbers, you know,
in case they had to back it out. There was that much confidence in v6. Right, right. Okay. And they made silly mistakes. i don't i still i haven't figured out i haven't bothered to look to see how they fixed it but they got rid of the protocol id field in v6 by saying it's the last option now the protocol id field tells you what protocol is encapsulated in ip and there's a registry for it at IANA with numbers, you know,|||以防他们不得不撤销它。当时对v6就是这么缺乏信心。对，对。好吧。而且他们还犯了愚蠢的错误。我不知道，我至今还没弄明白，我也懒得去看他们是怎么修复的，但他们在v6中取消了协议ID字段，宣称它现在是最后一个选项了。协议ID字段本来是告诉你什么协议被封装在IP中，IANA有一个带编号的注册表，你知道的，
it's TCP, this is SCP, you know, whatever. But then there were options in IP as well. And it has a registry too, you know, and they have numbers. So they had assigned two different registries to the same field in the protocol. I mean, not long ago, I was watching some stuff on the v6 list, and they were trying to define the scope of various IPv6 addresses, and they couldn't do it. Now, what does the scope of an address mean? Where you can interpret it, and it means something, and it doesn't mean something else. Ah, okay. Right? I mean mean you know um luckily mac addresses are global right but um in some cases you might have a protocol where the address is only known within the layer ah got it right i mean private addresses are essentially two holes in the public IP address space. Right, yep.
it's TCP, this is SCP, you know, whatever. But then there were options in IP as well. And it has a registry too, you know, and they have numbers. So they had assigned two different registries to the same field in the protocol. I mean, not long ago, I was watching some stuff on the v6 list, and they were trying to define the scope of various IPv6 addresses, and they couldn't do it. Now, what does the scope of an address mean? Where you can interpret it, and it means something, and it doesn't mean something else. Ah, okay. Right? I mean mean you know um luckily mac addresses are global right but um in some cases you might have a protocol where the address is only known within the layer ah got it right i mean private addresses are essentially two holes in the public IP address space. Right, yep.|||比如这是TCP，这是SCTP，等等。但当时IP中也有选项。它也有一个注册表，你知道的，它们也有数字。所以他们把两个不同的注册表分配给了协议中的同一个字段。我的意思是，不久前，我在看v6邮件列表上的一些内容，他们试图定义各种IPv6地址的作用域（scope），结果他们根本做不到。现在，地址的作用域是什么意思？也就是你可以在哪里解释它，它在哪里有意义，而在哪里没有意义。啊，好吧。对吧？我的意思是，你知道，嗯，幸运的是MAC地址是全局的，对吧？但是，嗯，在某些情况下，你可能会遇到这样一种协议：其中的地址只在该层内部可知。啊，明白了，对吧？我的意思是，私有地址本质上就是公共IP地址空间中的两个洞。对，是的。
They have a different scope. They're only known within the private network. Actually, this is just segwaying a little bit here. Yeah, actually, getting back to the original thing we said about the refrigerator, if let's say we all adopted IPv6, now all of a sudden you don't have network address translation and so how do you protect your refrigerator then you know i've always wondered that don't ask me man i just walked into it
They have a different scope. They're only known within the private network. Actually, this is just segwaying a little bit here. Yeah, actually, getting back to the original thing we said about the refrigerator, if let's say we all adopted IPv6, now all of a sudden you don't have network address translation and so how do you protect your refrigerator then you know i've always wondered that don't ask me man i just walked into it|||它们有不同的作用域。它们只在私有网络内部可知。其实，这里稍微扯远一点。对，事实上，回到我们之前关于冰箱的那个话题，假设我们都采用了IPv6，现在突然之间你没有了网络地址转换（NAT），那么你该如何保护你的冰箱呢？你知道，我一直很好奇这一点。别问我，老兄，我只是刚好踩进这个坑里而已。
no i feel like you'll still end up with if not a complete translation layer you'll still end up with something that says oh you need you know you need permission to access the refrigerator like the refrigerator must have already talked to you or something see that there's several things that have gone wrong here i mean i think we mentioned last time that you know the sockets interface is probably the worst api you could have and if you if you work it out logically from the IPC model, just, you know, as I said, start with two applications in one computer. How does it work? And just keep, you know, two applications in two computers and so on. The address should never be exposed across the layer boundary.
no i feel like you'll still end up with if not a complete translation layer you'll still end up with something that says oh you need you know you need permission to access the refrigerator like the refrigerator must have already talked to you or something see that there's several things that have gone wrong here i mean i think we mentioned last time that you know the sockets interface is probably the worst api you could have and if you if you work it out logically from the IPC model, just, you know, as I said, start with two applications in one computer. How does it work? And just keep, you know, two applications in two computers and so on. The address should never be exposed across the layer boundary.|||不，我觉得你最终还是会有一个——如果不是一个完整的转换层的话——你最终还是会有某种机制，比如“哦，你需要，你知道的，你需要权限才能访问冰箱”，就像冰箱必须已经和你对话过或者类似的事情。看，这里有几件事情彻底搞砸了。我的意思是，我想我们上次提到过，套接字（sockets）接口可能是你能遇到的最糟糕的API。如果你从IPC（进程间通信）模型的逻辑来推导它，就像我说的，从一台计算机中的两个应用程序开始。它是如何工作的？然后一直推演下去，两台计算机中的两个应用程序，等等。地址永远不应该暴露在层边界之外。
In the world that I would have, an address – actually, what's really interesting is the entity within the layer, whatever you want to call it, process, library, thread, you know, I don't care. If that's the entity, actually, I consider it a process. And it has an application process name just like any other. I mean, you know, just because, I mean, it's nice to give it a different name because when you're talking about applications and the thing in the layer, having the same word doesn't help much, right? You like to put a signature. So, yeah, okay, fine. Big deal. But the thing is that it has an application name of its own. The address is a synonym whose scope is only known within the layer and may be structured to facilitate its use in the layer. In other words, know where it is. Okay. But the address should never be seen outside the layer.
In the world that I would have, an address – actually, what's really interesting is the entity within the layer, whatever you want to call it, process, library, thread, you know, I don't care. If that's the entity, actually, I consider it a process. And it has an application process name just like any other. I mean, you know, just because, I mean, it's nice to give it a different name because when you're talking about applications and the thing in the layer, having the same word doesn't help much, right? You like to put a signature. So, yeah, okay, fine. Big deal. But the thing is that it has an application name of its own. The address is a synonym whose scope is only known within the layer and may be structured to facilitate its use in the layer. In other words, know where it is. Okay. But the address should never be seen outside the layer.|||在我所构想的世界里，一个地址——实际上，非常有趣的是，层内的实体，无论你管它叫什么，进程、库、线程，你知道的，我不在乎。如果那是那个实体，实际上，我认为它就是一个进程。它拥有和其他进程一样的应用程序进程名。我的意思是，你知道的，仅仅因为……给它起个不同的名字挺好的，因为当你同时谈论应用程序和层中的那个东西时，用同一个词并没有什么帮助，对吧？你喜欢加上一个标识。所以，好吧，行。没什么大不了的。但关键在于，它有自己的应用程序名。地址是一个同义词，其作用域仅在层内可知，并且可以进行结构化设计，以便于在层内使用。换句话说，知道它在哪里。好的。但这个地址永远不应该在层外被看到。
So, yeah, can you dive into that and help me understand? So let's say I want to go to Google, right? So I open up my browser, I type google.com, and so DNS turns that into an IP address. Whoa, whoa, whoa, back up. DNS was a mistake. DNS was a massive step backwards. So how would it work?
So, yeah, can you dive into that and help me understand? So let's say I want to go to Google, right? So I open up my browser, I type google.com, and so DNS turns that into an IP address. Whoa, whoa, whoa, back up. DNS was a mistake. DNS was a massive step backwards. So how would it work?|||所以，能深入讲讲这个，帮我理解一下吗？假设我想访问谷歌，对吧？所以我打开浏览器，输入google.com，然后DNS把它转换成一个IP地址。哇，哇，哇，等一下。DNS是个错误。DNS是一个巨大的倒退。那它会怎么运作呢？
Because I'm having a hard time hypothesizing. The API that we had, I think I mentioned this last time, the API we had when we put the first unix system on the net made it look like files. Oh, so I would go to slash Google and Google would own that path somehow. You would have a, actually, there's a lot of implicit stuff in when you're saying Google.
Because I'm having a hard time hypothesizing. The API that we had, I think I mentioned this last time, the API we had when we put the first unix system on the net made it look like files. Oh, so I would go to slash Google and Google would own that path somehow. You would have a, actually, there's a lot of implicit stuff in when you're saying Google.|||因为我很难凭空假设。我们拥有的那个API——我想我上次提到过，当我们把第一个Unix系统连上网络时，我们拥有的那个API让它看起来像是文件。哦，所以我去访问/Google，然后Google在某种程度上拥有那个路径。你会有……实际上，当你提到“Google”时，里面包含了很多隐含的东西。
Actually, what you're saying is connect me to HTTP at Google.com, right? Okay. Actually, the application name for that might be http slash google slash com. Ah, I see. Yeah. Right? I mean, just like, you know, when we did the first one, we said, you know, the example I gave was, you know, you'd say, you know, open UCSD slash telnet, right?
Actually, what you're saying is connect me to HTTP at Google.com, right? Okay. Actually, the application name for that might be http slash google slash com. Ah, I see. Yeah. Right? I mean, just like, you know, when we did the first one, we said, you know, the example I gave was, you know, you'd say, you know, open UCSD slash telnet, right?|||实际上，你真正说的是“把我和Google.com上的HTTP连接起来”，对吧？好吧。实际上，它的应用程序名可能是http/google/com。啊，我明白了。是的。对吧？我的意思是，就像，你知道的，当我们做第一个例子时，我给出的例子是，你知道的，你会说“打开UCSD/telnet”，对吧？
Yeah, right. Okay. So the thing is, all DNS does, all DNS is DNS is a macro for an IP address. You know, the browser makes it implicit because it's a browser that you want to connect to port 80 rather than port 23. Right. Yep. Yep. Okay. So there's a lot going on there. And, you know, all this has just been heaped on, you know, as I said, you know, if we had done an API that looked like files. So, first of all, no applications would have had to be modified to use the net.
Yeah, right. Okay. So the thing is, all DNS does, all DNS is DNS is a macro for an IP address. You know, the browser makes it implicit because it's a browser that you want to connect to port 80 rather than port 23. Right. Yep. Yep. Okay. So there's a lot going on there. And, you know, all this has just been heaped on, you know, as I said, you know, if we had done an API that looked like files. So, first of all, no applications would have had to be modified to use the net.|||是的，没错。好吧。所以问题是，DNS所做的一切——DNS本质上只是IP地址的一个宏。你知道的，浏览器之所以隐式地这样做，是因为它是一个浏览器，它认为你想连接到80端口而不是23端口。对。没错。没错。好吧。所以里面有很多复杂的机制。而且，你知道的，所有这些都是后来堆砌上去的，正如我所说，如果我们设计了一个看起来像文件的API。那么，首先，没有任何应用程序需要为了使用网络而进行修改。
Oh, that's interesting. Let's think about this. So, so if an application wanted to... Oh, I see what you're saying. So if an application wanted to receive traffic from another application over IPC or from the net, it would be the same code. Yeah, that makes sense. Yep, yep. Yeah, of course.
Oh, that's interesting. Let's think about this. So, so if an application wanted to... Oh, I see what you're saying. So if an application wanted to receive traffic from another application over IPC or from the net, it would be the same code. Yeah, that makes sense. Yep, yep. Yeah, of course.|||哦，这很有意思。让我们想想看。所以，如果一个应用程序想要……哦，我明白你的意思了。所以，如果一个应用程序想要通过IPC或从网络接收来自另一个应用程序的流量，代码将是完全一样的。是的，这说得通。没错，没错。是的，当然。
What else would you do? Yeah, that's a good point. You know, it is kind of strange. Why would you do? Yeah, that's a good point. It is kind of strange. Oh, because we are doing sockets. Yeah, sockets do kind of work that way.
What else would you do? Yeah, that's a good point. You know, it is kind of strange. Why would you do? Yeah, that's a good point. It is kind of strange. Oh, because we are doing sockets. Yeah, sockets do kind of work that way.|||你还能怎么做呢？是的，这倒是个好观点。你知道的，这确实有点奇怪。你为什么要……是的，这倒是个好观点。这确实有点奇怪。哦，因为我们在搞套接字。是的，套接字差不多就是那样工作的。
You can open a file or you can open a network socket. But yeah. No, if, you know, and so if we'd had that and had application names
You can open a file or you can open a network socket. But yeah. No, if, you know, and so if we'd had that and had application names|||你可以打开一个文件，也可以打开一个网络套接字。但是，是的。不，如果，你知道的，如果我们当时有了那个，并且有了——
of the form I was saying, then we could have gotten rid of well-known ports. We would have application names. Right, right. Right. And no one would have been the wiser. It would have just happened.
of the form I was saying, then we could have gotten rid of well-known ports. We would have application names. Right, right. Right. And no one would have been the wiser. It would have just happened.|||像我刚才说的那种形式的应用程序名，那么我们就可以摆脱那些知名端口（well-known ports）了。我们将拥有应用程序名。对，对。对。而且神不知鬼不觉。一切自然而然就发生了。
Yeah, that makes sense. You know, nobody would have, you know, wouldn't have have just happened. Yeah, that makes sense. Nobody would have... It's a really good point. Just to put an example on this, we set up a Minecraft server. I have young kids and they play Minecraft. We set up a Minecraft server
Yeah, that makes sense. You know, nobody would have, you know, wouldn't have have just happened. Yeah, that makes sense. Nobody would have... It's a really good point. Just to put an example on this, we set up a Minecraft server. I have young kids and they play Minecraft. We set up a Minecraft server|||是的，这说得通。你知道，没有人会……事情就这么自然发生了。是的，这说得通。没有人会……这真是一个很好的观点。举个例子来说，我们搭建了一个《我的世界》（Minecraft）服务器。我有几个年幼的孩子，他们玩《我的世界》。我们搭建了一个《我的世界》服务器，
and my kid had to know Minecraft runs on port 27,000 something and then I had to go, OK, Minecraft runs on port, you know, 27000 something. And then I had to go into my router and I'm not a networking guy. I mean, I'm a total Luddite here. I had to go on my on my router and find the port and forward it. But but to your point, it'd be so much better if I could just say, you know, slash Minecraft, just forward slash Minecraft. Well, you know, and the other thing is, you know, when you connect to a well-known port, you get a new clean instance of that application.
and my kid had to know Minecraft runs on port 27,000 something and then I had to go, OK, Minecraft runs on port, you know, 27000 something. And then I had to go into my router and I'm not a networking guy. I mean, I'm a total Luddite here. I had to go on my on my router and find the port and forward it. But but to your point, it'd be so much better if I could just say, you know, slash Minecraft, just forward slash Minecraft. Well, you know, and the other thing is, you know, when you connect to a well-known port, you get a new clean instance of that application.|||然后我的孩子必须知道《我的世界》运行在27000多的端口上，然后我不得不去想，好吧，《我的世界》运行在，你知道的，27000多的端口上。然后我不得不进入我的路由器——我可不是个网络专家，我的意思是，在这方面我完全是个勒德分子（反对技术的人）——我得登录我的路由器，找到端口并进行端口转发。但正如你所说，如果我只需要输入，你知道的，/Minecraft，只需输入斜杠Minecraft，那就太好了。嗯，你知道的，另一件事是，你知道的，当你连接到一个知名端口时，你会获得该应用程序的一个新的干净实例。
How do I connect to a specific instance of an application? Yeah, there's no way. There's no way. How do I connect to a specific instance of an application with two different protocols? Yeah, no way to do that either. Right. But if you had application names and you had the full addressing architecture,
How do I connect to a specific instance of an application? Yeah, there's no way. There's no way. How do I connect to a specific instance of an application with two different protocols? Yeah, no way to do that either. Right. But if you had application names and you had the full addressing architecture,|||我该如何连接到应用程序的特定实例呢？是的，根本没办法。根本没办法。我怎么用两种不同的协议连接到应用程序的特定实例？是的，这也是做不到的。对。但如果你拥有应用程序名和完整的寻址架构，
it's no problem. Well, how would you multiplex that? You know, like let's say, you know, for example, you go to slash Google, like Google is going to have thousands of instances of that application. Ah, but isn't Google then a distributed application
it's no problem. Well, how would you multiplex that? You know, like let's say, you know, for example, you go to slash Google, like Google is going to have thousands of instances of that application. Ah, but isn't Google then a distributed application|||这就没问题了。那么，你将如何对其进行多路复用（multiplex）呢？你知道的，比如，假设，你去访问/Google，而Google会有成千上万个该应用程序的实例。啊，但Google难道不是一个分布式的、
that is doing its own load sharing? Is Google its own? Yes. Right. Google has a load balancer and all of that. They're handling all of that. I connect to, you know,
that is doing its own load sharing? Is Google its own? Yes. Right. Google has a load balancer and all of that. They're handling all of that. I connect to, you know,|||正在自己做负载均衡的应用程序吗？Google是它自己的……是的。没错。Google有负载均衡器以及诸如此类的东西。它们在处理所有这些。我连接到，你知道的，
maybe I have an Anycast, it's an Anycast. Maybe the Google application name is Anycast that connects me to the nearest one. And they say, ah, the least loaded guy who's going to provide you the best service is this one over here and we'll
maybe I have an Anycast, it's an Anycast. Maybe the Google application name is Anycast that connects me to the nearest one. And they say, ah, the least loaded guy who's going to provide you the best service is this one over here and we'll|||也许我有一个任播（Anycast），这是一个任播。也许Google的应用程序名是一个任播，它把我连接到最近的那一个。然后他们会说：“啊，负载最低、能为你提供最好服务的家伙是这边这个，我们将——”
hand it to him. Oh, that's true. Just because you're using paths, it doesn't mean you don't have redirects. You get redirected to the real application. But it all becomes their application's job to do right right that makes sense perfectly normal so but you know but because of ip you know well because they never developed the application layer the ip address ip was a disaster to start with um you probably don't know how ip mobility works but it's's a disaster. I've never heard that before. Yeah. You have to explain IP mobility. Is that cell phone internet at a high level?
hand it to him. Oh, that's true. Just because you're using paths, it doesn't mean you don't have redirects. You get redirected to the real application. But it all becomes their application's job to do right right that makes sense perfectly normal so but you know but because of ip you know well because they never developed the application layer the ip address ip was a disaster to start with um you probably don't know how ip mobility works but it's's a disaster. I've never heard that before. Yeah. You have to explain IP mobility. Is that cell phone internet at a high level?|||把它交给他。哦，确实如此。仅仅因为你使用的是路径，并不意味着你不会遇到重定向。你会被重定向到真正的应用程序。但这全都成了他们应用程序自己的工作，对，对，这完全说得通，非常正常。所以，但是，你知道，但因为IP，你知道，好吧，因为他们从未开发过应用层，IP地址/IP从一开始就是一场灾难，嗯，你可能不知道IP移动性（IP mobility）是怎么工作的，但那简直是一场灾难。我以前从没听过这个说法。是的。你得解释一下什么是IP移动性。这在宏观上是不是就是手机上网？
Yeah. Well, there's all sorts of protocols for this. I mean, you know, proposals for this. And the way IP mobile. OK, remember, in the IP world, the only thing you have a hold of is the IP address. It's the only identifier you've got. Why in the Mac right mac address yeah but mac addresses are local i mean you can't reach a mac address like you can't say connect
Yeah. Well, there's all sorts of protocols for this. I mean, you know, proposals for this. And the way IP mobile. OK, remember, in the IP world, the only thing you have a hold of is the IP address. It's the only identifier you've got. Why in the Mac right mac address yeah but mac addresses are local i mean you can't reach a mac address like you can't say connect|||是的。嗯，有各种各样的协议来处理这个。我的意思是，你知道，有相关的提案。而IP移动性的工作方式……好吧，记住，在IP世界里，你唯一能抓得住的东西就是IP地址。这是你拥有的唯一标识符。为什么不看Mac，对吧，MAC地址。是的，但MAC地址是局部的，我的意思是，你无法直接通过MAC地址访问，就像你不能说“连接——”
me to this mac address at least not that i know of no and and there's a whole other set of problems there but anyway because that's the only thing you have a hold of now you have and and the address is telling you where it is now right because it's lighter now you want to move so how do i know where you are okay yeah interesting all right so my router tables tell me worldwide you know where these guys are so the way IP mobility works is if I go someplace, I connect to one of their routers and I say, hey, my home router is over there across the country. Create a tunnel from my home router to here for me, because this IP address is going to be on your interface X. Wait, so what is the use case here? I'm sorry, what?
me to this mac address at least not that i know of no and and there's a whole other set of problems there but anyway because that's the only thing you have a hold of now you have and and the address is telling you where it is now right because it's lighter now you want to move so how do i know where you are okay yeah interesting all right so my router tables tell me worldwide you know where these guys are so the way IP mobility works is if I go someplace, I connect to one of their routers and I say, hey, my home router is over there across the country. Create a tunnel from my home router to here for me, because this IP address is going to be on your interface X. Wait, so what is the use case here? I'm sorry, what?|||到这个MAC地址”，至少据我所知不能。不，而且那里还有一整套其他问题。但无论如何，因为那是你唯一能抓得住的东西，现在你有了……并且地址正在告诉你它现在在哪里，对吧？因为现在设备变轻便了，你想移动，那么我怎么知道你在哪里呢？好吧，是的，很有趣。好吧，所以我的路由表告诉我全球范围内这些家伙在哪里。所以IP移动性的工作方式是：如果我去某个地方，我连接到他们的一个路由器，然后我说：“嘿，我的家用路由器在远处的那个地方。请为我从我的家用路由器到这里创建一个隧道，因为这个IP地址将挂载在你们的X接口上。”等等，那这里的应用场景是什么？对不起，什么？
What's the use case here? Mobility. It's like when you say mobility, I interpret that as cell phones. Is that correct? Am I getting that right? Well, we're talking about moving laptops around too. Okay, so if I, well, help me understand this because, you know, if I take my laptop and I go to a hotel or something, I'm going to get a new IP address, right?
What's the use case here? Mobility. It's like when you say mobility, I interpret that as cell phones. Is that correct? Am I getting that right? Well, we're talking about moving laptops around too. Okay, so if I, well, help me understand this because, you know, if I take my laptop and I go to a hotel or something, I'm going to get a new IP address, right?|||这里的应用场景是什么？移动性。就像当你提到“移动性”时，我把它理解为手机。对吗？我理解得对吗？嗯，我们也在讨论带着笔记本电脑到处跑的情况。好吧，如果我……嗯，帮我理解一下这个，因为，你知道，如果我拿着笔记本电脑去酒店什么的，我会得到一个新的IP地址，对吧？
Oh, you're talking about like if I have like multiple like Wi-Fi with the same SSID and I'm roaming? Let's say you were moving around. Let's say with your phone you're moving around, okay? If you want to keep the same TCP connection, you don't get a new address. Oh, I see what you're saying. So you're saying, let's say we're, let's say we're streaming audio and we're in the car. And so we're hopping from cell tower to cell tower. You know, we're, we're moving physically, but we need to have the same address. Well, you do and you don't. Okay. Right now, IP is floating on top of the cell phone system, using it, okay, as if it were one big network.
Oh, you're talking about like if I have like multiple like Wi-Fi with the same SSID and I'm roaming? Let's say you were moving around. Let's say with your phone you're moving around, okay? If you want to keep the same TCP connection, you don't get a new address. Oh, I see what you're saying. So you're saying, let's say we're, let's say we're streaming audio and we're in the car. And so we're hopping from cell tower to cell tower. You know, we're, we're moving physically, but we need to have the same address. Well, you do and you don't. Okay. Right now, IP is floating on top of the cell phone system, using it, okay, as if it were one big network.|||哦，你是说像我有多个具有相同SSID的Wi-Fi并且我在漫游的那种情况吗？假设你在四处移动。假设你带着手机在移动，好吗？如果你想保持同一个TCP连接，你就不能更换新地址。哦，我明白你的意思了。所以你是说，比方说我们正在……比方说我们正在听音频流，而且我们在车里。所以我们在基站（cell tower）之间切换。你知道的，我们在物理上移动，但我们需要拥有相同的地址。嗯，可以说有，也可以说没有。好吧。目前，IP悬浮在手机系统之上，使用它，好把它当作一个大网络来用。
Of course, the thing has been, how do we do it with IP and replace all that cell phone stuff down below? The problem is that you've got, all you've got is the IP address. And they've made a few improvements, but it's still a real mess. Basically, because that's the only thing you have to hang on to. You have to come up with a tunnel from your home agent or router to the foreign guy that you're currently talking to. So that when you send out packets with your IP address and they go across the network to a server and he turns around and sends using your source address, sends it back to you. It's going to go to your home router who's going to put it in a tunnel, send it to the foreign router and hand it to you. OK, got it.
Of course, the thing has been, how do we do it with IP and replace all that cell phone stuff down below? The problem is that you've got, all you've got is the IP address. And they've made a few improvements, but it's still a real mess. Basically, because that's the only thing you have to hang on to. You have to come up with a tunnel from your home agent or router to the foreign guy that you're currently talking to. So that when you send out packets with your IP address and they go across the network to a server and he turns around and sends using your source address, sends it back to you. It's going to go to your home router who's going to put it in a tunnel, send it to the foreign router and hand it to you. OK, got it.|||当然，问题一直是：我们如何用IP来做到这一点，并取代底层所有的手机通信技术？问题是，你拥有的全部东西只有IP地址。尽管他们做了一些改进，但这仍然是一团糟。基本上，因为那是你唯一可以依附的东西。你必须想办法从你的归属代理（home agent）或路由器到你当前与之通信的外部设备之间建立一条隧道。这样，当你用你的IP地址发送数据包，它们穿过网络到达服务器，而服务器转过头来使用你的源地址将数据包发回给你时，数据包会先到达你的家用路由器，由它将其放入隧道，发送给外部路由器，然后再交给你。好的，明白了。
OK, this gets crazy. OK, if you're moving now from cell tower to cell tower, we're tearing down tunnels and bringing it back up. This is getting really cumbersome. Right. Right. Okay. If you have a full addressing architecture with application names, then you just, you know, things change down below and nobody has to, you know, you don't need any tunnels. If you move too far, and this is the neat part, if you move too far and you want to change your address so it aggregates, you assign, taking the definitions I used earlier, you assign a new synonym to the process with the address of where you are in the network now.
OK, this gets crazy. OK, if you're moving now from cell tower to cell tower, we're tearing down tunnels and bringing it back up. This is getting really cumbersome. Right. Right. Okay. If you have a full addressing architecture with application names, then you just, you know, things change down below and nobody has to, you know, you don't need any tunnels. If you move too far, and this is the neat part, if you move too far and you want to change your address so it aggregates, you assign, taking the definitions I used earlier, you assign a new synonym to the process with the address of where you are in the network now.|||好吧，这太疯狂了。好吧，如果你现在从一个基站移动到另一个基站，我们就得拆除隧道并重新建立隧道。这变得非常笨重。对。对。好吧。如果你有一个包含应用程序名的完整寻址架构，那么你只需要……你知道的，底层的局势变了，但没有人需要……你知道的，你根本不需要任何隧道。如果你移动得太远——这是最妙的部分——如果你移动得太远，并且想要改变你的地址以便于聚合，你可以——采用我刚才用过的定义——为该进程分配一个新的同义词，附带你在当前网络中所处位置的地址。
You tell via the management connection, but you're changing source addresses for all connections that originate here. You start advertising the new address. You stop advertising the old address. And it just works. Right, right. That makes sense. Right? stop advertising the old address and it just works. Right. Right. That makes sense. Right. And it, you know, and it happens just, you know, seamlessly. And, you know, in fact, you don't even need any new protocols, you know?
You tell via the management connection, but you're changing source addresses for all connections that originate here. You start advertising the new address. You stop advertising the old address. And it just works. Right, right. That makes sense. Right? stop advertising the old address and it just works. Right. Right. That makes sense. Right. And it, you know, and it happens just, you know, seamlessly. And, you know, in fact, you don't even need any new protocols, you know?|||你通过管理连接进行通知，但你正在为所有源自这里的连接更改源地址。你开始宣告新地址。你停止宣告旧地址。然后一切就顺畅运行了。对，对。这说得通。对吧？停止宣告旧地址，然后一切就顺畅运行了。对。对。这说得通。对。而且它，你知道的，它发生得非常无缝。并且，你知道的，事实上你甚至不需要任何新的协议，你知道吗？
And this, this is grossly simpler than what 5G is doing. What is 5G doing? Look, I can't even begin to explain that. Okay. I've seen 5G diagrams that have seven layers below the network layer. Oh, okay. All right. I mean, it's just, you know, you want to glaze over real fast. Go read about 5G.
And this, this is grossly simpler than what 5G is doing. What is 5G doing? Look, I can't even begin to explain that. Okay. I've seen 5G diagrams that have seven layers below the network layer. Oh, okay. All right. I mean, it's just, you know, you want to glaze over real fast. Go read about 5G.|||而且这比5G正在做的事情要简单得多。5G在做什么？看，我甚至无法开始解释那个。好吧。我见过5G的架构图，在网络层下面居然有七层。哦，好吧。行吧。我的意思是，这简直……你知道的，如果你想让眼神迅速失去焦点（觉得无聊/头大），去读读关于5G的资料吧。
Okay. I was, I mean, not to get us too sidetracked, but basically, I know folks who got 5G home internet, and that's actually pretty powerful. I was really surprised. I was very skeptical, but it works extremely well. From what I understand, the physical layer stuff is pretty good. The network layer stuff is... But, you know, I mean, you can hide a lot these days. I mean, look at Bluetooth. Oh, my God. Yeah. Bluetooth works really well, right?
Okay. I was, I mean, not to get us too sidetracked, but basically, I know folks who got 5G home internet, and that's actually pretty powerful. I was really surprised. I was very skeptical, but it works extremely well. From what I understand, the physical layer stuff is pretty good. The network layer stuff is... But, you know, I mean, you can hide a lot these days. I mean, look at Bluetooth. Oh, my God. Yeah. Bluetooth works really well, right?|||好吧。我——我的意思是，为了不让我们偏离主题太远，但基本上，我知道有些人用上了5G家庭宽带，那东西其实挺强大的。我真的很惊讶。我本来非常怀疑，但它运行得非常好。据我所知，物理层的东西相当不错。网络层的东西则是……但是，你知道的，我的意思是，如今你可以隐藏很多东西。我是说，看看蓝牙。哦，天哪。是的，蓝牙工作得非常好，对吧？
Yeah. I mean, I seem to always have issues with it, but maybe it's just me. No, no, no. It's not just you. I mean, I have the problem I have now, which is like the one car and a train of problems is I have Bluetooth headphones that and I don't know how this works, but they're paired to my laptop and my. And so there's some kind of cleverness that tries to, you know, figure out which one to actually get the audio. For some reason, you know, my laptop will be shut in my backpack, in my car, the trunk of my car. I'll be in the passenger side.
Yeah. I mean, I seem to always have issues with it, but maybe it's just me. No, no, no. It's not just you. I mean, I have the problem I have now, which is like the one car and a train of problems is I have Bluetooth headphones that and I don't know how this works, but they're paired to my laptop and my. And so there's some kind of cleverness that tries to, you know, figure out which one to actually get the audio. For some reason, you know, my laptop will be shut in my backpack, in my car, the trunk of my car. I'll be in the passenger side.|||是的。我的意思是，我似乎总是有各种问题，但也许只是我个人的问题。不，不，不。不只是你。我的意思是，我现在遇到的问题是——就像一辆车带出一连串问题一样——我有一副蓝牙耳机，我不知道它是怎么运作的，它们同时与我的笔记本电脑和我的……进行了配对。因此，某种“智能”机制试图去判断到底应该将音频发给哪一个设备。出于某种原因，你知道的，我的笔记本电脑放在背包里，关机放在车里，放在我汽车的后备箱里。而我坐在副驾驶座上。
Yeah, I'll be in the passenger side of the car. My laptop totally shut. And then my headphones will hand off from my phone, which is, you know, three inches away or a foot away't know, a foot away, to my laptop, which shouldn't even be on. And so it's like one of many issues I've had. Well, let me guess. They're both Macs, right? The laptop's a Mac. The phone's an Android.
Yeah, I'll be in the passenger side of the car. My laptop totally shut. And then my headphones will hand off from my phone, which is, you know, three inches away or a foot away't know, a foot away, to my laptop, which shouldn't even be on. And so it's like one of many issues I've had. Well, let me guess. They're both Macs, right? The laptop's a Mac. The phone's an Android.|||是的，我坐在汽车的副驾驶座上。我的笔记本电脑完全处于关机状态。然后我的耳机竟然会从距离我只有三英寸或一英尺远的手机——不知道，一英尺远——切换连接到那台根本不应该开机的笔记本电脑上。所以这只是我遇到的众多问题之一。好吧，让我猜猜。它们都是苹果电脑吧？笔记本电脑是Mac。手机是安卓。
Oh, okay. Well, all right. I have a similar problem with a pair of Bluetooth headphones I have up here so I can watch tv while my wife is asleep and it pairs to my laptop i still haven't figured out how to get it to talk to my laptop and not talk to the tv it says it's pairing to both of them but it clearly isn't yep yep it's clear there's some there's some problem there they just fix that. No, Bluetooth is a mess of special cases. It's gotten better since it first came out,
Oh, okay. Well, all right. I have a similar problem with a pair of Bluetooth headphones I have up here so I can watch tv while my wife is asleep and it pairs to my laptop i still haven't figured out how to get it to talk to my laptop and not talk to the tv it says it's pairing to both of them but it clearly isn't yep yep it's clear there's some there's some problem there they just fix that. No, Bluetooth is a mess of special cases. It's gotten better since it first came out,|||哦，好吧。好吧。我有一副放在这里的蓝牙耳机也有类似的问题，这样我就可以在妻子睡觉时看电视了。它和我的笔记本电脑进行了配对，但我至今还没弄明白怎么让它只跟笔记本电脑连接而不去连电视。它显示它同时与两者进行了配对，但显然并没有。对，对，很明显那里存在一些问题。他们刚刚修复了那个。不，蓝牙简直是各种特殊情况（special cases）的乱麻。自从它问世以来，情况有所改善，
but it was one of the worst protocol designs I've ever seen. So spiraling up a little bit, actually, can we do anything in sort of user space to improve this? Like, can you build, like, do you have to sort of, is there anything we can build on top of what we already have to make this any better? Well, there are two really bad problems. Okay, one is this addressing problem. Okay, the other one is the congestion problem. The congestion control scheme we have in TCP is pretty terrible, mainly because it works by causing congestion.
但它是我见过的最糟糕的协议设计之一。所以稍微跳脱出来一点，实际上，我们在某种程度上能在用户空间做点什么来改善这一点吗？比如，你能构建——我是说，有没有什么东西我们可以建立在我们已有的基础之上来让情况变得更好一点？嗯，有两个非常糟糕的问题。好吧，一个是寻址问题。好吧，另一个是拥塞问题。我们在TCP中采用的拥塞控制方案相当糟糕，主要是因为它是通过引发拥塞来起作用的。
Yep. Yep. So that one probably is hard to fix for us. And also because they detect congestion by drop packets, it's predatory. If you try and do anything below it that happens to drop a packet, you're going to get feedback mechanisms warring with each other. Okay. And so there's no nice fix. And basically, the thing is, this is another case where at the time, we had a better solution. We have a solution that was based on explicit notification that started notification when the average queue length in the router was greater than or equal to one.
没错。没错。所以那个问题对我们来说可能很难解决。而且由于它们是通过丢包来检测拥塞的碰巧丢了包的任何底层操作，都会导致反馈机制彼此冲突。好吧。所以并没有什么完美的修复方案。基本上，情况是这样的，这是另一个例子，在当时，我们其实有更好的解决方案。我们有一个基于显式通知的方案，当路由器中的平均队列长度大于或等于一时，它就会开始发出通知。
In other words, very early. Nip it in the bud so you can back off and not lose packets. Right? Because, I mean, with what we have now, the fact that you have to detect lost packets means the queues are full and they've been throwing stuff away. Right. Yep. So those are retransmissions.
换句话说，非常早。防患于未然，这样你就可以退避而不会丢包。对吧？因为，我是说，就我们目前的情况而言，你必须检测到丢包，这就意味着队列已经满了，而且它们一直在丢弃数据。对吧。没错。所以这些就是重传。
And the longer it takes to recognize that, the more retransmissions you're generating. Yeah, that makes sense. I'm going to jump in here and interrupt our interview today to talk about our sponsor, Zencastr. Zencastr is an all-in-one podcast production suite that gives you studio-quality audio and video without needing all that technical know-how. It records each guest locally, then uploads the crystal-clear audio and video right into the suite, so you have high-quality raw materials to work with. Jason and I have been using Zencastr for programming Throwdown for a while now, and it's a huge upgrade over the way we used to do things.
而且识别出这一点所需的时间越长，你产生的重传就越多。是的，这说得通。我要在这里打断一下我们今天的采访，来介绍一下我们的赞助商Zencastr。Zencastr是一个一体化的播客制作套件，它能为你提供录音室级别的音频和视频，而无需你掌握那些复杂的技术知识。它会在本地录制每个嘉宾的音视频，然后将清晰无比的音视频直接上传到套件中，这样你就能获得高质量的原始素材来进行了。我和杰森在做Programming Throwdown时使用Zencastr已经有一段时间了，相比我们以前的做法，这是一个巨大的升级。
It's so much easier and more seamless to have everybody join a Zencastr room and get individual audio streams for each participant, which allows editing and mastering to go much more quickly. It just also feels like a better experience for all involved. I'm so happy that we have this new solution instead of the way we used to do things back when we first started. If you would like to try Zencastr to make your own podcast, you can get a free trial by going to zen.ai slash programming throwdown. That's zen.ai slash programming throwdown. Back to the podcast. What about the other issue? I feel like the addressing issue,
让每个人加入一个Zencastr房间，并为每个参与者获取各自的音频流，这要简单和无缝得多，这使得剪辑和母带制作能够进行得快得多。对于所有参与的人来说，这也感觉是一次更好的体验。我很高兴我们有了这个新解决方案，而不是像我们刚开始做的时候那样。如果你想尝试用Zencastr来制作你自己的播客，你可以通过访问 zen.ai slash programming throwdown 来获得免费试用。网址是 zen.ai slash programming throwdown。回到播客。另一个问题怎么样？我觉得寻址问题，
I feel like that's solvable with another layer on top that, you know, almost like a, like, SCTP or one of these things where you say, here's a list of, you know, interfaces. I know I'll point to the same node, and I'm just going to like SCTP or one of these things where you say, here's a list of interfaces. I know I'll point to the same node. I'm just going to use SCTP to just get me there. Remember, multi-homing is a problem of delivery, not sending. Wait, what's the difference there? Well, the thing with multi-homing is
我觉得这可以通过在上面加一层来解决，你知道，几乎就像是一个，比如SCTP或者诸如此类的东西，你说，这里是一个接口列表。我知道我会指向同一个节点，然后我就要像SCTP或类似的东西那样，说，这里是一个接口列表。我知道我会指向同一个节点。我只是要用SCTP把我带到那里。记住，多归属（multi-homing）是一个交付问题，而不是发送问题。等等，这两者有什么区别？嗯，多归属的问题在于
if one interface goes down, I know what the other one is to use. But it's also a quality of service, right? It's sort of picking the best one. Yeah, but that's a whole different thing. Got it. Okay. I mean, first of all, congestion is doing you more harm on quality of service than the addressing is. Oh, definitely. I feel like the congestion is probably hard to fix. Yeah. No, I mean, first of all,
如果一个接口挂了，我知道该用另一个。但这也是服务质量的问题，对吧？它有点像是在挑选最好的一个。是的，但那是完全不同的另一回事。明白了。好吧。我的意思是，首先，拥塞对你服务质量造成的损害要比寻址大得多。哦，肯定的。我觉得拥塞可能很难修复。是的。不，我的意思是，首先，
nobody thought about putting congestion in the transport layer until the internet ran into the problem. They were all going to put it in the network layer where they could come, they could coordinate it with quality of service. But now you've got these functions in the network layer trying to make the traffic smooth and you've got TCP pulsing it. Right. I mean, you're working against each other. And part of that's because they lost the Internet layer. You know, if you had the two bottom layers. The way we, you know, in fact, in fact, the NWIG, the International Network Working Group had had the right answer in 1975, but the Internet lost the Internet layer. Yeah, I mean, to your point, you know, I mean, even to this day, I really have a far from lucid understanding of IP.
在互联网遇到问题之前，没有人考虑把拥塞放在传输层。他们原本都打算把它放在网络层，在那里他们可以将其与服务质量进行协调。但现在，网络层里有这些功能试图让流量平滑，而TCP却在给它脉冲。对吧。我的意思是，你们在互相使绊子。部分原因是因为他们丢掉了互联网层。你知道，如果你拥有最下面两层。就像我们（你知道）——事实上，1975年国际网络工作组（NWIG）就已经有了正确的答案，但是互联网弄丢了互联网层。是的，我的意思是，说到你的观点，你知道，我的意思是，直到今天，我对IP的理解也远远称不上清晰透彻。
I'm definitely, you know, I understand, like, my understanding is you can do TCP, you can do UDP if you're willing to tolerate some packet loss. And I know that they sit on top of IP academically, but I don't have an understanding of what that actually means. I think a lot of engineers are in that boat. Well, yeah, it's not really key. There's a lot of stuff that gets really complicated in there. IP should probably never have been separated from TCP. You know, there's just one patch after another. And, you know, every time you do a patch, there's friction and the friction doesn't add up linearly. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Right. You know, and so, you know,
我绝对是，你知道，我明白——我的理解是你可以用TCP，如果你愿意容忍一些丢包的话你也可以用UDP。我知道它们在学术上是建立在IP之上的，但我并不理解这实际上意味着什么。我想很多工程师都有同感。好吧，是的，这其实不是关键。里面有很多东西变得非常复杂。IP大概本不应该跟TCP分开的。你知道，就是一个补丁接着一个补丁。而且，你知道，每次你打补丁，就会产生摩擦，而摩擦的累积并不是线性的。对吧。是的。是的。对吧。你知道，所以，你知道，
I mean, for example, they, everything worked with, with TCP early on. Oh, well, as much as it could until, and they split IP and then IP fragmentation has never worked. And so, you know, then you have a, then you have a fix for that. The trouble is that doesn't work because it's turned out to be a denial of service attack. And just on and on and on. You could probably reduce the complexity of the net and increase the security by at least two orders of magnitude by fixing what's down below. Right. You know, and there's all sorts of things you wouldn what's down below.
我的意思是，举个例子，它们——早期一切都能跟TCP配合工作。哦，好吧，只要在它能承受的范围内直到后来他们把IP拆分了，然后IP分片就从来没正常工作过。所以，你知道，接着你就会有一个，然后你针对那个有个修复方案。问题是这根本不管用，因为它后来演变成了拒绝服务攻击。就这样没完没了。通过修复底层的机制，你大概可以把网络的复杂性降低、安全性提升至少两个数量级。对吧。你知道，还有各种各样你根本不需要的东西——底层的东西。
There's all sorts of things you wouldn't have to have. For example, you wouldn't need SIP. SIP is like a voice thing, right? It's been a while since I heard that. Well, that's what everybody thinks it has to do with. The fact of the matter is, it's how voice or IP solves the problem of connecting to a specific instance of an application. Ah, okay. Got it. Right?
有各种各样你根本不需要的东西。比如，你不需要SIP。SIP是个语音方面的东西，对吧？我听到这个词已经有一段时间了。嗯，那是所有人以为它跟什么有关的事实上，它的本质是VoIP（网络电话）如何解决连接到应用程序特定实例的问题。啊，好吧。明白了。对吧？
They were all their own. What does SIP stand for? Session Initiation Protocol. Ah, okay. Got it. Okay. It's how you resolve a phone number to an IP address in a port. Got it.
它们都是各自独立的。SIP代表什么？会话发起协议（Session Initiation Protocol）。啊，好吧。明白了。好吧。它是你如何将电话号码解析为一个IP地址和一个端口的方法。明白了。
Okay. Okay. But, you know, if you had application names. Yeah, you wouldn't have to do that. Wouldn't have to do that. So I wanted to, like, I want us to take just a little pause here. I want to jump into, you know, what we could do to make things better. But I'm really curious if you could humor me on this.
好吧。好吧。但是，你知道，如果你有了应用程序名称。是的，你就不必那样做了。不需要那样做。所以我想要——就像，我希望我们在这里稍微停顿一下。我想要探讨一下，你知道，我们可以做些什么来让事情变得更好。但我真的很想知道你能不能在这个问题上顺着我的思路聊聊。
Like, where do you make things better but i want to i'm really curious if you could uh humor me on this like where do you think things will go i think that that because i really don't know i feel like we're just stuck where you know ipv6 is i haven't even heard much about it lately and so i just like where do you think if you were to look into a crystal ball where do you think the internet architecture is going to go, if anywhere? The problem we have is thinking outside the box, okay? And going back to basics. Starting in 2000, and to some extent it's still going on, there's been a future internet effort. It hasn't come up with anything. Mainly, the reason is that the argument has been, well, there are new requirements on the network. Therefore, we need to do different things. It turns out that if you fix the flaws that were introduced, you not only don't need new things, you get things you didn't have before. But as I've
比如，你在哪里能让事情变得更好，但我想——我真的很想知道你能不能呃迁就我一下，聊聊这个，比如你认为事情会走向何方？因为我真的不知道，我觉得我们就卡在这里，你知道，IPv6——我最近甚至都没怎么听到过它的消息，所以我就想——如果你用水晶球展望一下，你认为互联网架构会走向何方（如果它还会发展的话）？我们面临的问题是跳不出固有思维模式，好吧？而且要回归基础。从2000年开始，在某种程度上现在还在继续，人们一直在做“未来互联网”的努力。但它什么也没搞出来。主要原因在于，争论的焦点一直是：嗯，网络有了新的需求。因此，我们需要做不同的事情。事实证明，如果你修复了引入的缺陷，你不仅不需要新东西，还会得到以前没有的东西。但正如我曾
had several, you know, full professors tell me, well, this is really hard because, I mean, the only thing I've ever seen is TCP. Okay. They, you know, but, you know, that shouldn't be a barrier. I mean, one of the things I've been, I think I'm, I've had a couple of long email discussions with some of the early people on addressing, you know, people who were there at the beginning, especially some of the Xerox PARC people. And the one thing that struck me was that they were all trying to fix the problems they had in front of them. No one was stepping back and saying, what's the big picture here? And things that I thought were indications that they were turned out that was wrong. Got it. Yeah. You know, but,
有几个，你知道，正教授对我说过的那样，嗯，这真的很难，因为，我的意思是我见过的唯一东西就是TCP。好吧。他们，你知道，但是，你知道，这不应该成为一个障碍。我的意思是，我一直在做的一件事是，我想我曾跟一些早期研究寻址的人进行过几次长篇大论的邮件讨论，那些从一开始就在的人，特别是施乐帕克（Xerox PARC）的一些人。让我震惊的一点是，他们当时都在试图解决眼前的问题。没有人退后一步去想想：这里的宏观全貌是什么？而那些我以为是转机迹象的事情，结果证明都搞错了。明白了。是的。你知道，但是，
you know, as opposed to the Ciclod guys, which I mentioned last time, who said, we're going to assume, you know, what are the minimal assumptions? Right. And then let's put that together and see what we have. And much to their shock, it was all they needed. Okay. To some extent, this whole thing about protocols, I went through, you know, and again, okay, so maybe it started earlier, but it shouldn't have. I've always, you know, there's a thing they teach in operating systems. Every OS book I've ever looked at talks about the separation of mechanism and policy.
你知道，相比之下，就像我上次提到的Ciclod那帮人，他们说，我们要假设——最起码的假设是什么？对吧。然后我们把这些组合起来看看我们得到了什么。令他们大跌眼镜的是，这就是他们所需要的一切。好吧。从某种程度上讲，关于协议的整个这套东西，我经历过，而且——好吧，所以也许它开始得更早，但它本不应该这样。我一直都觉得，你知道，操作系统里有个东西是他们会教的。我看过的每一本OS书都在讨论机制与策略的分离（separation of mechanism and policy）。
Yep. All right. It always seemed to me we ought to apply that to networks. Right. Yep. I mean, it ought to fit like a glove, man.
没错。好的。在我看来，我们似乎应该把它应用到网络中去。对吧。没错。我的意思是，这应该像手套一样完美契合才对，老兄。
Right. And so actually I did it, but I didn't do it by just, you know, coming up with them back in the early days we had, we were trying to specify protocols pretty well. And we had a pros outline form that we had for writing protocols there. And we actually took it to the point where we developed what we call RoboPros.
对吧。所以实际上我这么做了，但我不是通过——你知道，仅仅在早期我们试图把协议规范写得很好时凭空想出来的。我们当时有一种用于编写协议的散文大纲形式。我们甚至把它推进到了开发我们称之为RoboPros的阶段。
We realized that if you did what your rhetoric or English teacher taught you to do of, you know, don't say the same thing, you know, don't say things the same way twice, vary the language and all this stuff, was exactly what you didn't want to do in a specification. Nah. Because if you did, someone would say, well, he said it differently. So he must have meant something different. Right, right. Okay.
我们意识到，如果你照着你的修辞学或英语老师教你的去做，比如“不要重复说同一件事，不要把一句话说两遍，要变换语言”等等，这恰恰是你在编写规范时最不需要的东西。可不是嘛。因为如果你这么做了，就会有人说：“嗯，他换了一种说法。所以他一定是指别的东西。”对吧，对吧。好吧。
So we, we had it down to, you know, when you are in the X state and you get one of these, you do this. Yeah. Sort of pros. So I came up with an outline form for adding a new mechanism to a protocol. And then I religiously followed my outline, no matter how simple the mechanism was. Again, and I had no clue what was going to come out of this. Could have turned out to be a waste of time. But what fell out was I realized when I stepped back and looked at it,
所以我们把它精简到：当你处于X状态并且收到其中一个时，你就这样做。这种级别的散文体。所以我为向协议添加新机制设计了一种大纲形式。然后我虔诚地遵循我的大纲，不管这个机制有多么简单。同样地，我当时完全不知道这会产生什么结果。这完全有可能被证明是在浪费时间。但最终产出的是，当我退后一步审视它时，我意识到，
well, okay, the first one that was sort of an ankling that things were coming was I had done an outline for acknowledgments, right? I mean, the machinery is the same question as when you're going to acknowledge. And then I was going to do flow control. It was another mechanism, right? And we had that sliding window thing going on, right? So one night, I started doing these like one at a time. And, you know, in the evening, I forgot the kids to bed.
嗯，好吧，第一个隐约让我觉得有事情要发生的是，我曾为确认机制（acknowledgments）写过一份大纲，对吧？我的意思是，这个机制和你要在什么时候发送确认是同一个问题。然后我打算做流控（flow control）。那是另一个机制，对吧？我们当时正在弄那个滑动窗口的东西，对吧？所以有一天晚上，我开始像这样逐个处理它们。然后呢，你知道，在傍晚，我把孩子们哄上床睡觉。
And, you know, so I started doing it in down acknowledgement. And I noticed that I was only manipulating the left window edge. Well, that's kind of odd. I thought I'd at least have to refer to the right window edge. Well, I was going to do flow control tomorrow night, but I'm curious. So I did flow control, and I only referred to the right window edge. And then I said, of course, you idiot. The linkage is in the policy, right?
然后，你知道，所以我开始做下行确认（down acknowledgement）。我注意到我只在操作左窗口边缘。嗯，这有点奇怪。我以为我至少得引用右窗口边缘呢。好吧，我打算明天晚上做流控，但我很好奇。所以我做了流控，结果我只引用了右窗口边缘。然后我说：“废话，你这个笨蛋。连接关系是在策略里的，对吧？”
Well, duh. Yeah, right? Well, duh. Yeah, right. It makes sense. You know, light dawns on, you know, thick skull. And I went into this friend of mine, you know, doing this as long as I have, the next day at work and said, told him this insight. And he goes, well, you mentioned it. You know, it's obvious, but no, I hadn't thought about it either. But then I, the other thing that fell out of that was I realized that the mechanisms fell into two categories. Those that absolutely had to be with the data,
好吧，废话。是的，对吧？好吧，废话。是的，对吧。这说得通。你知道，冥顽不灵的脑袋终于开窍了。第二天上班时，我找到我的一个朋友——从事这行跟我一样久，把这个见解告诉了他。结果他说：“经你这么一提。你知道，这很显然，但确实，我之前也没想到过。”但随后我，从中得出的另一件事是，我意识到机制其实分为两类。那些绝对必须跟数据绑定在一起的，
the error check, sequence numbers, you know, things like that. And the thing is, it didn't have to be. They could be, but they didn't have to be. And those were the feedback mechanisms. Right. That makes sense. Yep. Right. And what I realized was the other thing, which was a real shock, was that the, I call those the ones that had to be with the data, tightly bound, they had to be with the data. It only wrote the state vector,
错误校验、序列号，你知道，诸如此类的东西。关键在于，其实不一定非得如此。它们可以这样，但不一定非得这样。另一类就是反馈机制。对吧。这说得通。没错。对吧。而我意识到的是另一件事，这真是个巨大的震撼，我把那些必须和数据在一起、紧密绑定的东西称为——它们必须和数据在一起。它只写入状态向量，
recorded what sequence number it had gotten and everything. The other side only read it. And the two pieces never talked to each other. Actually, the only time that they did was when the flow control window closed and the feedback side told the other side, don't send anything. That was it. Otherwise, they never talked. Now, and so when you're when you're designing these, I mean, I wasn't designing anything.
记录它收到了什么序列号以及所有这些。另一端只读取它。而这两部分从不互相交流。实际上，它们唯一交流的时候是当流控窗口关闭，反馈端告诉另一端：别发任何东西了。仅此而已。除此之外，它们从不交流。现在，所以当你——当你设计这些东西时——我的意思是，我当时没有设计任何东西。
Right. I was looking at the structure, you know, and I was doing a process, but I wasn't, you know, in much the same way with the IPC model, I was not skipping steps. You know, this designing a protocol that looked like TCP or TP4 or SATP or any of those things, you know, we'd done dozens of them, but we never done, A, the exercise of separating mechanism and policy. And, you know, we hadn't done a careful job of analyzing what the structure of the problem was. And I don't see researchers doing that at all. Actually, I've seen one other good example, which was Roz Jane's work on congestion.
对吧。我只是在观察结构，你知道，我当时在做一个过程，但我不像IPC模型那样，你知道，我没有跳过步骤。你知道，设计一个看起来像TCP、TP4、SATP或任何这些东西的协议，我们做过几十个了，但我们从来没有做过：A，分离机制和策略的练习。而且，你知道，我们没有对问题的结构进行仔细的分析。我根本没看到研究人员这样做。实际上，我见过的另一个好例子是罗兹·简（Raj Jain）关于拥塞的工作。
You know, everybody's looking to find an answer, not understand the problem space. Right, right. Okay. So, yeah, how do researchers do research on something like this? They have to build their own network, right, where they can invent new protocols. Like, they can't use routers off the shelf or any of that because that's all designed for the existing protocols right they well first of all they end up well okay this also has to do with how you get funding okay all right okay all right and who's gonna what will they fund and what do they understand well this is this is clearly, you know, the Renaissance period where the kings and the princes will fund brilliant people to do anything.
你知道，每个人都在寻找答案，而不是去理解问题空间。对吧，对吧。好吧。所以，是的，研究人员究竟是如何对这样的东西进行研究的呢？他们必须构建自己的网络，对吧，在那里他们可以发明新协议。比如，他们不能使用现成的路由器或诸如此类东西，因为那全都是为现有协议设计的，对吧？他们——首先，他们最终会——好吧，这也跟你是如何获得资助有关，好吧。行，好吧。行，好吧。谁会出资？他们会资助什么？他们又懂些什么？好吧，这显然是，你知道，文艺复兴时期，国王和王子们会资助才华横溢的人去做任何事。
No, it's definitely not big business coming in and dictating what people research. Sort of like a hint of sarcasm there. No, no, no. It really is. And also, you end up, you know, also people tend to build, they concentrate on a particular problem. Okay. And they'll sort of have an idea of what might work. And they go after that. And they build the rest of the context around it. Now, when I was doing the OSI work, I was the rapporteur for the reference
不，这绝对不是大企业进来并对人们的研究指手画脚。这里面有点讽刺的意味。不，不，不。真的就是这样。而且，最终你会发现，人们往往会去构建——他们专注于某个特定的问题。好吧。而且他们通常会有一种关于什么可能行得通的想法。然后他们就朝着这个方向去。并在它周围构建其余的上下文。现在，当我在做OSI工作时，我是参考模型及架构的报告人（rapporteur）。所以我被拉进了各个层级的讨论中。我看到了一些我觉得可以起到简化作用的模式。当然，我得到的借口总是：哦，是的，戴夫，但如果我们在这里简化，其他某个地方就会变得更复杂。好吧，我不知道——似乎一定有什么逻辑谬误来掩盖这一点。我不信。是的。好吧，我不相信的原因是，我们非常幸运。早在我们制造第一台超级计算机时，我们必须把这台计算机作为我们的机器，它可能是人类有史以来最精湛的计算机系统设计——巴勒斯5500（Burroughs 5500）。
model with the architecture. So I got pulled into all the discussions up and down the layers. And I saw some patterns go by that I thought would be simplifying. And of course, the excuse I always got was, oh yeah, Dave, but if we simplify here, it's just going to get more complex somewhere else. OK, I don't know if I it seems there's got to be like a logical fallacy to cover that. I don't believe it. Yeah. Well, and the reason I don't believe it is that we were very fortunate. Back when we were building the first supercomputer, we had to use as our computer probably the finest piece of computer system design ever done, the Burroughs 5500.
你得告诉我那是什么，因为我一无所知。对吧。哦，这远在你出生之前。事实上，这甚至有点在我出生之前。这台机器是1964年上市的。好吧。这台机器，我一直以来的描述方式是，如果你知道A是怎么工作的，B是怎么工作的，
You'll have to tell me what that is because I have no idea. Right. Oh, this is way before your time. In fact, this is even sort of before my time. This machine came on the market in 1964. Okay. This machine, the way I've always described it is if you knew how A worked and B worked,
你就能猜出C会怎么工作，而且你的猜测会是准的。啊，真棒。没有特例。一切都能正常工作。好吧。它是第一台使用栈（stack）的机器。好吧。等等，那是什么意思？
you could guess how C would work and you'd be right. Ah, nice. There were no special cases. Everything just worked. Okay. It was the first machine to use a stack. Okay. Wait, so what do you mean?
像调用栈（call stack）吗？所以它是一个——等等，真的吗？哦，我想是在60年代。是的。这是可能的。是的。我从来没真正想过这个。
Like a call stack? So it's, so it's a, wait, really? Oh, I guess in the sixties. Yeah. It's possible. Yeah. Yeah. I never really thought about that.
IBM现在还在这么做。我不认为。或者说他们在模拟它。这是一个零地址。想想看。这是一个零地址栈机器，没有通用寄存器。它有标签架构（tagged architecture）。栈被标记为不可执行。它是基于描述符的。所以如果你访问数组越界了，就会触发错误。
IBM still does it. I don't think. Or else they simulate it. This was a zero. Think about it. This was a zero address stack machine with no general purpose registers. It had a tagged architecture. The stack was tagged non-executable. It was descriptor based. So if you indexed off the end of an array, it was a fault.
每个寄存器都有其用途。它只用于那个用途，而且唯有那个用途。这听起来很像你在虚拟机里看到的那些东西，比如Java虚拟机之类的。而且很明显，机器的操作符是根据它们所需的功能开发出来的。哦，因为机器上最低级的语言是ALGOL，好吧？就像Pascal一样。对吧，对吧。好吧？ALGOL编译器是用它自身编写的。操作系统是用ALGOL的一个扩展版本（叫ESPAL）编写的。
Every register had a purpose. It was used for that purpose and that purpose alone. This is sounding a lot like the virtual machines that you see, like the Java virtual machine and stuff like that. And it was pretty clear that the machine operators' operations had been developed to fit what they needed. Oh, because the lowest level language on the machine was ALGOL, okay? Like Pascal. Right, right. Okay? The ALGOL compiler was written in itself. The operating system was written in an extension of ALGOL called ESPAL.
就像我说的，一切都正常工作。我最喜欢的例子之一，我简直不敢相信，上周二我的课上。你知道浮点数长什么样吗？哦，我想我们在过去的节目中讨论过这个。它们是反过来的吗？对吧，对吧，对吧。是的，是的。那非常巧妙。
And like I said, everything just worked. One of my favorites, I couldn't believe this, my class last Tuesday. You know what a floating point number looks like? Oh, I think we talked about this on the past show. Are they like reversed? Right, right, right. Yeah, yeah. That was extremely clever.
为什么其他人没有采用这种做法？啊，因为它需要更长的字长（word）。哦，好吧。明白了。大概吧。我不知道。但关键是，这东西真的很优雅。这教会了我们优雅的解决方案是确实存在的。
Why haven't other people adopted that? Ah, because it takes a longer word. Oh, okay. Got it. Probably. I don't know. But the thing was, this thing was really elegant. That taught us that elegant solutions existed.
对吧，对吧。好吧。这是有一件事，稍微退后一步，让事情变得更抽象一点——这是我们领域中一个真正被低估的方面，你知道，我觉得人们分为两大阵营，而这两个阵营在这个问题上都点偏离了目标：一个阵营说，你知道，我们要非常学究气、非常严格，嗯，你知道，所以然后，那就会拖慢开发进度；在频谱的另一端，则只是一种完全的混乱，而且是，你知道，让我们把这个产品推向市场，没有规则，一切都疯狂得要命，但是，存在着第三个正交的轴，那就是，你知道，你愿意在多大程度上改变事物的优雅程度以及为此投入的时间。并且我认为，你知道，人们花点时间停下来并说“好吧，我们构建了一些东西”是非常重要的。
Right, right. Okay. This is one thing, just stepping back a little bit, making things more abstract, like, this is one thing that's really underappreciated in our field is, you know, I feel like there's people who fall into two camps and both camp kind of missed the mark on this one camp says you know we're going to be really pedantic and really strict and um you know and so and so then you know that kind of slows the development on the other end of the spectrum it's just kind of total chaos and it's uh you know let's get this product out the door and there's no rules and everything's just crazy and but there is like a third orthogonal axis there, which is, you know, how much you are willing to vary sort of the elegance of something and the time spent on that. And I think that, you know, it's really important for people to take a moment and say, OK, we've built something.
我们从中学到了什么真正基础的东西？我们能不能带着那种先验（a priori）或后验（a posteriori）的知识把它重新构建一遍？嗯，我对此有一个理论。说来听听。是的。在物理学和化学等其他科学中，大自然把我们的脚按在离火炉很近的地方。如果你尝试构建一个分子或用物理学做一些违反规则的事情，它会立刻告诉你。在计算机科学中，我们有两个问题。第一，我们拥有的理论与现实严重脱节。
What did we learn from this? That's really fundamental? And can we build it over again with that a priori or a posteriori knowledge? Well, I have a theory on this. Let's hear it. Yeah. In the other sciences like physics and chemistry and stuff, nature holds our feet pretty close to the fire. If you try and build a molecule or do something with physics that violates the rules, it tells you real quick. In computing, we have two problems. One, the theory we have is very far disconnected from the reality.
你这话是什么意思？图灵机和自动机理论并没有告诉我太多关于如何构建计算机的信息。啊，好吧，明白了。对吧，对吧。对吧？你知道，另一方面，我们还面临这样一个问题：我们构建的就是我们所测量的。那么……哦，有趣。好吧，是的。我们看到的东西是一个我们无法绕过的基本原则，
What do you mean by that? Turing machines and automata theory don't tell me much about how to build a computer. Ah, okay, got it. Right, right. Right? You know, on the other hand, we also have the problem that we build what we measure. So is the... Oh, interesting. Well, yeah. Is the thing we're seeing a fundamental principle that we can't get around,
还是我们构建它的方式所带来的结果？这就是我们面临的两件事。这就是为什么你经常——我相信这就是为什么你通常会把第一个版本当作一次性抛弃的产品，因为在投入实现并犯下一些错误之前，你对权衡取舍的理解只能推进到一定程度。是的，是的。所以你可以看到，现在你开始明白权衡是什么了，你对问题的本质有了更好的理解。是的。我的意思是，一个很好的例子就是英特尔的处理架构，对吧？所以就像是，
or is it a consequence of how we build it? Those are the two things we have. This is why you often, I believe this is why you often, I believe this is why you often have the first one as a throwaway, because you can only take the design so far as to what the trade-offs are going to be before you dive into the implementation and make some mistakes. Yeah, yeah. So you can see, now you can begin to see what the trade-offs are, and you get a better idea of what the nature of the problem is. Yeah. I mean, a great example of this is Intel's processor architecture, right? So it's like,
他们怎么知道流水线应该有多长？他们需要多少个浮点协处理器？我的意思是，所有这些都是经验主义的。他们可能会调查他们的重要客户。他们可能会收集一些数据。然后他们说，好吧，我们需要——现在有更多的人在做浮点运算了。现在有人在挖比特币了。我们需要改变处理器架构。所以它是高度由反馈驱动的。
how did they know how big the pipeline should be? How many floating point coprocessors they need? I mean, all of this is empirical. They probably survey their big customers. They probably collect some data. And then they say, okay, we need to, there's more people doing floating point now. There's people mining Bitcoin now. We need to change the processor architecture. And so it's very feedback driven.
是的。事实上，甚至在早期，巴勒斯（Burroughs）就在分析用户代码中的指令序列，以便将它们放入硬件中。哦，有趣。是的。是的。我记得有一个——是Vax吗？但有一台机器在做类似的事情，它们甚至在硬件中做排序，人们想要的东西。对吧。是的。是的。我一直认为，精简指令集（RISC）和复杂指令集（CISC）之间的争论，与其说是复杂和精简之间的争论，不如说是硬件人员没有构建编译器所需的操作符。是的，这说得通。
Yeah. In fact, even in those early days, Burroughs was analyzing user code for sequences that they were going to put into hardware. Oh, interesting. Yeah. Yeah. I remember there's a, is it the Vax? But there was a, there was a machine that was doing something similar and they did like even sorting and hardware, you know, things that people wanted. Right. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I've always contended that the argument between RISC and CISC was not so much between complex and reduced, but that the hardware guys were not building the operators that the compiler needed. Yeah, that makes sense.
好的。也就是你先设计编译器，然后弄清楚你想让它拥有什么样的硬件操作符。对吧？然后你弄清楚你想让它拥有什么样的硬件操作符，对吧？而且，我的意思是，我记得当68000系列问世时，摩托罗拉会生产68000的新版本。当时的感觉就像是，伙计们，这些是很酷的复杂指令，但没有编译器，我是不会用它的。对吧，对吧。看在上帝的份上，我希望编译器帮我处理好记账工作。
Okay. That you design the compiler first, and then you figure out what hardware operators you wanted it to have. Right? Then you figure out what hardware operators you want it to have, right? And, I mean, I remember when the 68000s were coming out, that Motorola would produce a new version of 68000. It was like, guys, these are neat, complex instructions, but without a compiler, I'm not going to use it. Right, right. I want the compiler to do the bookkeeping for me, for God's sakes.
是的，这说得通。你知道，还有这样一种情况：“嗯，这是一个非常酷的指令，但为了使用它，我必须把所有这些东西移来移去，以便我能够使用它。”到那个时候，我自己早就该搞定了。对吧。是的。你知道，所以，你知道，这些总是权衡。现在，我认为我们在这一点上取得了突破。这听起来可能真的很奇怪，但我偶然读到了一本关于19世纪
Yeah, that makes sense. You know, and also this thing of, well, here's this really neat instruction, but in order to use it, I've got to move all this stuff around so I can use it. By that time, I should have just done it myself. Right. Yeah. You know, so, you know, those are always the tradeoffs. Now, I think we've made a breakthrough in that. And this is going to sound really weird, but I came across a book about a 19th century
逻辑学家的书，这不重要。在书的后面——这就是为什么在亚马逊上随便浏览并不划算的原因。（你知道，你不能看背面。）有这样一个整个子章节，讲的是逻辑学家们认定“抽象就是不变性（abstraction was invariance）”。这是一个醍醐灌顶的时刻。当我谈到“分离机制和策略”时，我一直在说什么？我一直在提取出不变性。当我说我分不清时，你知道，我患有拓扑学家的视觉缺陷，
logician, doesn't matter. And in the back of it, this is why browsing on Amazon isn't worthwhile. You know, I mean, you can't look at the back. There was this whole subchapter that the logicians had decided abstraction was invariance. And it was a head slap moment. What had I been saying when I said separate mechanism and policy? I had been pulling out the invariance. When I say I can't tell, you know, I suffer from the topologist's vision defect.
我分不清咖啡杯和甜甜圈。提取出不变性。我意识到，我在网络领域一直在做的练习，并不是把所有东西都强行塞进同一个模子里——这是很多人犯的错误。而是我提取出了不变的部分，并让需要变化的部分去变化。是的，说得通。对吧。而且，我也意识到，我构建模型的方式不是按照我想要的，而是按照问题告诉我的那样，并且不打破不变性。我的意思是，我可以在不同的层级上拥有不变性，对吧？你从一些非常普遍的不变性开始，然后你开始在不同的领域中落实它们。你对缩小它们的范围做出不同的决定。而我们发现，奇怪的是，我们从来没有遇到过魔鬼
I can't tell a coffee cup from a donut. Pulling out the invariances. What I realized that the exercise I had been going through with networking was letting, you know, not forcing everything into one mold, which is the mistake many people make. But I was pulling out the invariant stuff and letting the part that had to vary, vary. Yeah, makes sense. Right. And also, what I also realized was I was then constructing the model not the way I wanted to, but the way the problem told me to, and not break the invariances. I mean, I can have invariances at different levels, right? You start out with some very general invariances and you start making them in different areas. You make different decisions about, you know, narrowing them down. And what we found, strangely enough, was there was no, we didn't, we never encountered a devil
藏在细节里的情况。事实上，恰恰相反。我们会着手处理一个我们还没看过的全新主题，然后发现我们一直在使用的模型已经为我们解决了这个问题。哦，那太棒了。对吧？你知道，细节里其实有天使。对吧。所以，所以我们如何实现这一点呢？所以，你知道，我们在准备阶段稍微讨论了一下这个，但是，你知道，我们如何做到——我们讨论了一点事情将走向何方，而答案是，呃，你知道，在TCP上进行更多的研究，以及，你知道，某种渐进式的改变。我们究竟如何才能彻底打破这一切？
in the details. In fact, just the opposite. We'd pick up a new topic that we hadn't looked at yet and find out that the model we were working with had already solved it for us. Oh, that's nice. Right? That, you know, there were angels in the details. Right. So, so how do we get this? So, you know, we talked about this a little bit in prep, but, you know, how do we get, you know, we talked a bit about where things are going and the answer is, is, uh, you know, a lot more research in a TCP and, you know, kind of incremental changes. How do we actually, you we actually blow this up?
我们能把几个公司内部网迁移到某种新的东西上吗？这在实践中将如何运作？嗯，私人网络似乎在兴起。对吧，没错。我认为那是开始的地方。是的，这说得通。对吧。
Can we get a couple of company intranets onto something new? How would this work in practice? Well, there seems to be a rise in private networking. Right, yep. And I think that's the place to start. Yep, that makes sense. Right.
所以总结一下，实际上如果我理解错了请告诉我，因为我并不是100%确定，但举个例子，我的笔记本电脑，我有一台工作用的笔记本电脑。它就在这儿。现在没开机。但是——但是当它开机时，你知道，我们有一个VPN。所以这意味着，你知道，我的计算机正在通过我的家庭互联网等等进行隧道传输，当你在处于这个隧道中的时候，它在某种程度上是被隔离的，然后在某个时候它到达了隧道的另一端，也就是某个网络，你知道，不知何故像是工作系统内部的——所以从网络角度来看，这就好像我在办公室里一样。因此，使用一个私人网络，所以我理解——如果我在工作笔记本电脑上访问google.com，它实际上是——如果我错了请纠正我——从网络角度来看，它就像是先进入了公司内部，然后再从那里连接到Google。鉴于它是私有的
So just to recap, and actually tell me if I'm wrong about this because I'm not 100% certain, but for example, my laptop, I have a work laptop. It's right here. It's not turned on now. But but but when it's on, you know, we have a VPN. And so what that means is is, you know, my computer is is tunneling through my home Internet and all of that and it while you're in this tunnel it's sort of isolated and then at some point it gets the other end of the tunnel which is some network that is you know somehow like within the work system and so it's just as if i was in the office from a networking perspective and so with a private network and so i understand like if I go to google.com on my work laptop, it's actually, and please correct me if I'm wrong, it's like somehow going into work from a networking perspective and then connecting to Google from there. And so given that it's private
无论如何，你知道，我们在那里做一些更聪明的举措可能是可行的。嗯，而且你知道，另一件的事情是，你知道，很多奖励机制的方向都指错了。人们因为把事情搞得与众不同而受到奖励。事实上，在我的书里，我做了一个区分，当时我正试图弄清楚科学与工程之间的区别是什么。实际上，这两者都会做实验，对吧？我的意思是，那并不是一个——据我所理解的，对于科学，你通常从一个假设开始，然后你试图去验证它。对于工程，你从你想建造的东西的某种架构开始。
anyways, you know, it might be possible for us to do more clever things there. Well, and you know, the other thing is, you know, a lot of the reward structure is aimed in the wrong direction. People are rewarded for making things different. And in fact, in my book, I drew the distinction where I was trying to figure out what the difference between science and engineering was. And actually, both of them do experiments, right? I mean, that's not a – How I understand it is with science, you typically start with a hypothesis and then you're trying to validate it. With engineering, you start with a sort of an architecture of what you want to build.
嗯，我的结论是，在科学中，你对共性、不变性、事物之间的相似性感兴趣，并利用这种相似性。在工程中，你想极尽所能地利用差异。是的，这说得通。这说得通。是的，我的意思是，这有点符合。就像科学一样，你从一个假设开始，
Well, what I came to was in science, you're interested in the commonalities, in variances, the similarities between things, leveraging that similarity. In engineering, you want to exploit the hell out of the differences. Yeah, that makes sense. That makes sense. Yeah, I mean, that kind of goes along. Like with science, you start with a hypothesis
希望它会是一些非常简短的东西，甚至是一句话。是的。因此，为了达到那种抽象水平，你必须完全做你刚才所说的事情。对于工程来说，就像是，你知道，目标是一个巨大的架构图。所以你试图，你知道，
which is going to be hopefully some really short, maybe even a one-liner. Yeah. And so to get that level of abstraction, you have to do exactly what you were saying. For engineering, it's like, you know, the goal is this huge architectural diagram. And so you're trying to, you know,
把每个部分——榨干每一块石头里的水。嗯，但话又说回来，这又归结为找出差异是什么。我的意思是，你知道，我们得出的结论是没有五层或七层。只有一个不断重复的层。你可以把它用于许多不同的事情。你知道，你的VPN只是另一层，你知道，
kind of get every piece, you know, squeeze the water out of the rock on every piece of there. Well, but again, that comes back to finding out what the variances are. I mean, you know, the conclusion we've come to is that there aren't five or seven layers. There's one layer that repeats. You can use that for a lot of different things. You know, your VPN is just another layer, you know,
而且在某些情况下，你可能会把其他层与它结合起来，你知道。但是，你知道，正如我所说，当我们这样做时，各种各样的事情都冒了出来，而我们之前毫无——你知道，这一切都来自于我前面描述的那个IPC模型，你知道，它非常通用，非常，你知道，初级的，非常基础的。但另一方面，事实证明，这一层是一个可确保安全的容器，我们基本上不需要防火墙，该层的所有成员都经过了身份验证。另一个完全出乎意料的成果是，你不需要全局地址空间，但你仍然可以访问每个应用程序。这说得通。是的。
and on occasion you may join other layers with it, you know. But, you know, and as I said, when we did that, all sorts of things fell out that we had no, you know, it all came out of that IPC model thing I described earlier, you know, which was very general and very, you know, rudimentary, you know, very elementary. But on the other hand, it turned out that the layer was a securable container, that we basically didn't need firewalls, that all members of the layer were authenticated. One that fell out that we didn't expect at all was that you don't need a global address space, but you can still reach every application. That makes sense. Yeah.
因此，这大大增强了安全性。是的，类似于——如果我可以为听众做一个类比的话——这类似于你有文件夹，而文件夹有安全性。所以，你知道，如果我试图访问别人的主目录，它是不允许的。因此，默认情况下，它不允许我查看任何子目录中的任何文件。你知道，它是以这种递归的方式处理的。对吧。你知道，所以，你知道，但话说回来，通过提出不变性——我们有了一点术语膨胀。我的意思是，我不想——我的意思是，我不想踩到太多人的脚，但是……我们的实际通货膨胀也很严重。
And so that enhances security a lot. Yeah, similar to, if I could draw the analogy for folks in the audience, it's similar to how you have folders and folders have security. So, you know, if I try and go to someone else's home directory, it won't let me. And then therefore, like, by default, it won't let me see any file in any subdirectories. You know, it's handled in a recursive way like that. Right. You know, and so, you know, but again, by coming up with the invariances and we've got a little bit of term inflation. I mean, I don't want to I mean, I don't want to step on too many toes, but. We have a lot of real inflation, too.
所以你并不孤单。但是很多拥有“架构师”头衔的人实际上更多的是总工程师。那才是他们真正的角色。好吧。我的意思是，我曾跟某人讨论过这个问题。我总是指出的一点是，它们——你知道，什么是架构？它是一种建造风格。维多利亚式建筑与按照维多利亚式建筑建造的建筑物之间是有区别的。等等，你能——让我思考一下这个。所以一座按照维多利亚式建造的建筑物，所以这座建筑物是该架构的一个实例。对吧。而且它具有某些特征，使其成为维多利亚式的。对吧，对吧，但是维多利亚式建筑本身是一种抽象，它是抽象，你永远无法完全达到它，你知道，它是——是的，好吧，这说得通。然后基本上，在某种程度上，我意识到另一件事，哦，早在70年代，首先，模式识别器是罕见的，每个人——人类总体上是优秀的模式识别器，但有些人总体上是优秀的模式识别器，但有些人就是在这方面特别擅长。
So you're in good company. But a lot of people who have the title architect are really more chief engineers. That's really their role. Okay. I mean, I had this discussion with somebody. One of the things I always point out is that they're, you know, what is an architecture? It's a style of construction. There's a difference between Victorian architecture and a building built to
你知道，他们能看到别人注意不到的模式，你知道，他们很罕见。他们是那些必须想出理论的人。而且，你知道，那时的我开始变得明显，我们要么必须开发出工具，以便少数能写出真正优秀代码的人能够编写所有必须编写的代码，否则就会是一片混乱，对吧？要么我们必须把东西放出去，
Victorian architecture. Wait, can you, let me resonate on that. So a building built to Victorian, so the building is an instance of the architecture. Right. And it has certain characteristics that make it be Victorian. Right, right but victorian architecture itself is sort of this abstraction is the abstraction you never totally reach it you know it's uh yeah okay that makes sense and then basically to some extent the other thing this is something i realized oh back in the 70s is first of all pattern recognizers are rare every humans in general are good pattern recognizers but there are some people general are good pattern recognizers, but there are some people who are just really good at it.
以便那些不那么优秀的人也能做好并把事情做对。对吧，对准。要么这样，要么那样。好吧，这两者我们都没做到。是的。对吧？而且，你知道，关于不变性的整个这次突破，
You know, they see patterns that others don't pick up on, you know, and they're rare. They're the guys who have to come up with the theory. And, you know, it became apparent to me back then that we were either going to have to come up with tools so the few people who could write really good code could write all the code that had to be written or it was going to be bedlam, right? Or we had to put stuff out there
你知道，他们能看到别人察觉不到的模式，你知道，而且他们很罕见。他们是那些必须提出理论的人。而且，你知道，我当时就清楚地意识到，要么我们得开发出工具，让那些少数能写出真正优秀代码的人写出所有必须写的代码，否则就会乱成一团，对吧？或者我们得把东西推向市场
so that people who were not good could do it and get it right. Right, right. One or the other. Well, we haven't done either one. Yeah. Right? And, you know, this whole breakthrough with invariance,
好让那些不那么擅长的人也能做并且做对。对，对。要么这样，要么那样。嗯，这两样我们都没做到。是啊。对吧？而且，你知道，关于不变性的整个突破，
I mean, we've talked about abstraction in computer science forever, you know, this whole breakthrough with invariance, I mean, we've talked about abstraction in computer science forever, you know. And actually, one of the things that scares me is people tell me that the RINA stuff that we talk about is, quote, too abstract. It's like, guys, this is computer science. This is what we're supposed to be good at. Right, right. And believe me, RINA isn't category theory or algebraic topology. You know, on the scale of abstraction, it's not all that abstract. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So one thing here is, is, you know, there's, this is, this is piquing the interest of like, you know, tons of folks
我的意思是，我们在计算机科学中讨论抽象已经有很长时间了，你知道的，这种关于不变性的重大突破，我的意思是，我们在计算机科学中讨论抽象已经有很长时间了，你知道的。事实上，让我感到害怕的事情之一是，人们告诉我，我们谈论的 RINA 技术“过于抽象”了。这就好比，伙计们，这是计算机科学。这本来就是我们应该擅长的领域。对，对。而且相信我，RINA 既不是范畴论，也不是代数拓扑。你知道的，在抽象的尺度上，它并没有那么抽象。嗯，嗯。嗯。所以这里的一点是，你知道的，这，这，这激起了像，你知道的，无数人的兴趣
out there. And I'm sure a lot of people are, you know, maybe they're in undergrad, maybe they're in high school, right? And so they're saying, this is awesome. I want to work on the future of the internet. What do you recommend to those people? Like what sort of career advice would you give them? Or, you know, what would be sort of a path for them if this is something that really charges them up? I wish I knew. All right. I really wish I knew. see this stuff firsthand. You know, I, you know, you need, you know, and you're probably, if you're going to actually do it, you probably have to read widely and, and think about it a lot on your own.
在外面。而且我确信很多人，你知道的，也许他们正在读本科，也许他们在读高中，对吧？所以他们在想，这太棒了。我想致力于互联网的未来。你对这些人有什么建议？你会给他们什么样的职业建议？或者，你知道的，如果这真的是能让他们充满激情的事物，对他们来说怎样的道路会比较合适？我希望我知道。好吧。我真的很希望我知道。亲眼见证这些东西。你知道，我，你知道，你需要，你知道的，如果你真的打算去做，你可能不得不广泛地阅读，并且，并且自己去深入思考。
Try and get with good people, you know? But the thing is, and that was another thing where we were really lucky, you know, we had a group of very smart people of which I was the least and, and they put me through the ringer. And we had a professor who was not related to computer science at all. He was one of the founders of cybernetics who didn't tolerate sloppy thinking. And he really put us through the ringer. And what we learned from our sessions with him, we applied to ourselves, you know, and really debated this stuff. You know, again, I think it comes back to stepping back and taking the big picture,
试着和优秀的人在一起，你知道吗？但关键是，这也是我们非常幸运的另一点，你知道的，我们有一群非常聪明的人，而我是其中最不聪明的一个，他们把我放在炉火中千锤百炼。我们有一位与计算机科学毫无关系的教授。他是控制论的创始人之一，容不得半点含糊不清的思维。他真的把我们放在火上烤了。我们从与他的交流中学到的东西，我们应用到了自己身上，你知道的，并且真正地对这些东西进行了辩论。你知道，再说一次，我认为这归结为退一步看全局，
you know. Yeah, you may be working on a specific thing for work right now, okay, but how do you think it fits with all the other solutions? Where are the generalities, okay? What makes sense? If it doesn't fit, it's, you know, I think, I mean, right now we're working with three basic rules of the road. Maximize invariance and minimize discontinuities.
你知道的。是的，你现在可能正在做工作中某个特定的事情，好的，但是你认为它如何与所有其他的解决方案相契合？共性在哪里，好的？什么才合乎逻辑？如果它不契合，那就，你知道的，我的意思是，现在我们正遵循着三个基本的行事规则。最大化不变性，最小化不连续性。
That's a highfalutin way of saying no special cases. And if you think about it, a special case is breaking the invariance. That's why it's a special case. Do what the problem says. It's smarter than we are, you know, study the problem. And in fact, one of my favorite quotes by Kettering is a problem well-defined is a problem half solved. Yeah, definitely. You know, so, you know, all that stuff that people say, oh, we don't have time to do that. We don't have time not to do that, you know. And, you know, I've always been a big believer that good design was made better code than line-by-line optimization.
这是一个浮夸的说法，意思就是没有特例。如果你仔细想想，特例就是在打破不变性。这就是为什么它是特例。按照问题说的去做。它比我们更聪明，你知道的，去研究问题。事实上，凯特林我最喜欢的一句名言是，定义明确的问题就等于解决了一半。是的，绝对是。所以，你知道的，所有那些人们说“哦，我们没有时间做那个”的话，我们其实没有时间不去这样做，你知道的。而且，你知道的，我一直坚信，好的设计比逐行优化能写出更好的代码。
You know, the real collapses in complexity come when you go, oh, wait a minute. If we look at it this way, it's much simpler. Yeah. You know, you know, those are the things and it's a talent, you know, I mean, I'll never be a violinist, a virtual violinist or a painter or any, you know, anything else, or even maybe, you know, you know, turn out, you know, a thousand lines of code a day. In fact, one of the guys I work with today was my office mate in the 70s. He and I have been together for 50 years. Right. He's a dynamite implementer.
你知道的，当你说“哦，等一下。如果我们这样看，它要简单得多”时，复杂性才会真正发生崩塌。是的。你知道的，你知道的，这些就是重点，这是一种天赋，你知道的，我的意思是，我永远不会成为一个小提琴家，一个虚拟小提琴家或画家，或者任何，你知道的，其他什么，甚至也许，你知道的，你知道的，一天产出几千行代码。事实上，今天和我一起工作的其中一个人是我70年代的办公室室友。他和我已经在一起50年了。对。他是一个极厉害的实现者。
Right. And we bounce off each other. You know, he sees things I don't. I see things he doesn't. You know, and, you know, but, you know, it, it, but you, you know, I think reading widely is, is really key. That is a really good call out. You know, when I was a undergrad, I really didn't read a lot. Um, you know, we would get these assignments. Well, yeah, that's, that's true too. But, but, uh, I feel like, like, you know, later on when I went back and read the papers on all these topics, you even go back and read papers from the 60s and the 70s and you read about sort of you could see the sort of genesis of the methods and you could see the historical patterns and then you could place yourself in history and say, okay, here is
对。我们互相启发。你知道的，他能看到我看不到的东西。我能看到他看不到的东西。你知道的，而且，你知道的，但是，你知道的，它，它，但是你，你知道的，我认为广泛阅读真的是关键。这真是一个很好的呼吁。你知道的，当我读本科时，我其实没有读很多书。嗯，你知道的，我们会接到这些作业。嗯，是的，这也是真的——但是，但是，呃，我觉得，就像，你知道的，后来当我回去阅读所有这些主题的论文时，你甚至可以回过头去阅读60年代和70年代的论文，你可以读到，你可以看到这些方法的起源，你可以看到历史模式，然后你可以把自己置于历史之中，然后说，好吧，这里是
what needs to happen next in this narrative that's spanning a whole bunch of people, a whole bunch of years. But it's like, okay, now this is the next chapter that has to be written. It's very hard to do that if you don't read a lot. Right. I'll throw you a real curve. My first semester in graduate school in CS, when I went back after I got a master's in AA, the only course I took was the social ecology of the Amazon basin. Okay. All right. One of the best courses I've ever had.
在这个跨越了无数人和无数年的宏大叙事中，接下来需要发生什么。但这就好比，好吧，现在这是必须写出的下一章。如果不广泛阅读，是很难做到这一点的。好吧，我给你出个真正的难题。我在读计算机科学研究生院的第一学期，在我获得应用数学硕士学位后回去的那次，我选的唯一一门课程是亚马逊盆地的社会生态学。好吧。好吧。这是我上过的最好的课程之一。
I have no interest in the Amazon basin in any major way. Okay. But when I read the description of the course, I said, this is going to be good. So why? What stood out? The professor had assembled guest lecturers and looked at every aspect of what was going on in the Amazon. OK, we had lecturers from geology, geography, biology, ecology, economics, politics, Spanish
我对亚马逊盆地没有任何重大的兴趣。好吧。但是当我读到这门课的描述时，我心想，这肯定不错。所以为什么呢？有什么特别突出的地方？教授邀请了客座讲师，从各个方面审视了亚马逊正在发生的事情。好的，我们的讲师来自地质学、地理学、生物学、生态学、经济学、政治学、西班牙语
and Portuguese literature, the IMF, the World Bank, okay, on and on and on. In that course from the project, he pointed me at a guy in the business school who turned me on to a theory of organizations called the garbage can model, which is all about business, how organizations behave under high degrees of uncertainty. OK, that has been a guiding thing for me ever since, because I don't know any organizations that are operating under high degrees of uncertainty. Yeah, I mean, all the time, you know. In fact, one of the things I point out in my lecture on, say, network management is that managing the network is a low uncertainty problem and it better stay that way. Right. Because if the network's down or the electric grid is down, you know, there's bad things happening. Right. Right. So it's got to be insulated.
和葡萄牙语文学、国际货币基金组织、世界银行，好的，等等等等。在那门课的项目中，他把我引荐给商学院的一个人，那个人让我了解了一种名为“垃圾桶模型”的组织理论，这完全是关于商业的，关于组织如何在高度不确定性的情况下表现。好吧，从那以后，这一直指导着我，因为我不知道有什么组织不是在高度不确定性的情况下运作的。是的，我的意思是，一直都在，你知道的。事实上，我在关于网络管理的讲座中指出的一点是，管理网络是一个低不确定性的问题，而且最好一直保持这样。对。因为如果网络瘫痪了或者电网瘫痪了，你知道的，就会有坏事发生。对。对。所以它必须得到保护。
And, you know, and the model actually brings out all sorts of good advice. Like don't put high uncertainty projects in low uncertainty divisions. How many times have you seen that done? Right. And vice versa. My favorite is for high uncertainty projects, hire people with low degrees of self-confidence. Why? High uncertainty. Yeah. Like that. How, why is that? You don't want somebody who thinks he knows the answer. Ah, okay. Got it. You want somebody who's always going to be doubting that they've actually looked at everything.
而且，你知道的，这个模型实际上带出了各种好的建议。比如，不要把高不确定性的项目放在低不确定性的部门里。你见过多少次这种做法？对。反之亦然。我最喜欢的是，对于高不确定性的项目，雇用那些自信心较低的人。为什么？高不确定性。是的。就像这样。怎么，为什么会这样？你不会想要一个自以为知道答案的人。啊，好吧。明白了。你会想要一个总是怀疑自己是否真的把所有事情都看透了的人。
Ah, interesting. Okay. And the advice to the president is never, under any circumstances, make a decision. If you're the president. Now, yeah, it's funny, right? If you're the details. As you move up, your decisions have to be more and more abstract. By the time you get to the president, what you're doing is setting direction and setting environment. It's the only thing you can do safely. Right, right. Yep. Okay. This is something that I experienced and a lot of other people experienced where we go through this phase where we move into leadership and we still want to hold on to all the code that we wrote.
啊，有意思。好吧。对总编辑（总统）的建议是，无论在什么情况下，都不要做决定。如果你是总编辑。现在，是的，这很有趣，对吧？如果你是细节。随着你职位上升，你的决策必须越来越抽象。当你走到总编辑的位置时，你所做的是设定方向和设定环境。这是你能安全做到的唯一事情。对，对。是的。好吧。这是我经历过的事情，也是许多其他人经历过的事情，我们经历了这样一个阶段：我们进入了领导层，但我们仍然想要抓住我们写的所有代码不放。
You know, and we were an engineer at the same company. And so we started seeing these changes go by and, you know, you start wanting to jump in and make all these contributions. And then at some point, I realized that, you know, with the amount of time that I had left over to do these things after I was doing my real job, I just was not making good decisions as opposed to somebody who's there 40 hours a week minimum. And also, don't you feel like you're walking on ice? I don't know what that metaphor means, but maybe. You worry that they're doing what you would have done? Oh, interesting. Yeah, yeah, right, right.
你知道的，我们曾经是同一家公司的工程师。所以我们开始看到这些改变不断发生，你知道的，你开始想要跳进去做出所有这些贡献。然后到了某个时刻，我意识到，你知道的，在我做完我的真正工作后剩下用来做这些事情的时间里，比起一个每周至少在那里40小时的人来说，我做出的决策确实不够好。而且，你不觉得你如履薄冰吗？我不知道这个比喻是什么意思，但也许吧。你担心他们做的事情会是你原本会做的事？哦，有意思。对，对，对，对。
I mean, are they seeing the things that you would have seen? Right, right. All of that. Oh, gosh, yeah, absolutely. Yeah, so we have a few minutes left. So I wanted to give time to you to give advice to the folks out there. We have a lot the folks out there? We have a lot of kids out there.
我的意思是，他们看到了你会看到的那些东西吗？对，对。所有这些。哦，天哪，是的，绝对是。是的，我们还剩几分钟。所以我想留点时间给你，向外面的人给出建议。我们有很多外面的朋友？我们有很多年轻人在外面。
And what is the best advice you can give to folks, high school, college, maybe even young professionals, old professionals, what's your best advice that you can give to all of us? Unfortunately, the best advice I give runs counter to the way universities are pushing us today. Okay, all right. I start every one of my courses with the statement that this is a course in learning how to think. We're going to use networking or operating systems as the case study, but this is a course in learning how to think.
你能给人们最好的建议是什么，高中生、大学生，甚至可能是年轻的专业人士、老资历的专业人士，你能给我们所有人最好的建议是什么？不幸的是，我给出的最好建议与今天大学推动我们的方式背道而驰。好吧，好吧。我的每门课程都是以这样一句话开头的：这是一门学习如何思考的课程。我们将以网络或操作系统作为案例研究，但这本质上一门学习如何思考的课程。
And I start with a quote from John Henry Newman from 1856 that says, the purpose of the university is to create a habit of mind that lasts a lifetime. You're in a university. It's like a walking encyclopedia. Use it. If you get a break. And that, to some extent, I think we had more freedom to do that when I was in school. Today, school is so expensive and everything. You know, you don't take things on a lark. Interesting. Yeah. You know, it's, you know, it's all about getting a job. This is the time to really get a, you know, at least an exposure to as wide a group, as wide a bunch of stuff as you can.
我引用了约翰·亨利·纽曼 1856 年的一句话作为开场白，他说，大学的目的是培养一种持续一生的思维习惯。你身处大学。它就像一本会走路的百科全书。去利用它。如果你能得到一个喘息的机会。而且，在某种程度上，我认为我在学校时有更多的自由去这样做。今天的学校太贵了，什么都贵。你知道的，你不会心血来潮去选课。有意思。是的。你知道的，这一切都是为了找工作。这是真正去接触，你知道的，至少尽可能广泛地接触一个庞大群体、大量事物的绝佳时机。
You know, you know, one of the best, you know, another one of the best courses I had as an undergrad was a you can, you know. One of the best, you know, another one of the best courses I had as an undergrad was a drama course, reading plays, you know. I ended up with a really brilliant TA who went on to write screenplays in Hollywood and actually founded a local version of Second City and a theater, you know, and was doing some great stuff. But I mean, but the thing is, you know, the biological theater, you know, and was doing some great stuff. But I mean, but the thing is, you know, the biological sciences, you know, all of that stuff.
你知道，你知道，最好的之一，你知道，我作为本科生上的另一门最好的课程是你可以，你知道。最好的之一，你知道，我作为本科生上的另一门最好的课程是一门戏剧课，阅读戏剧，你知道。我最后遇到了一位非常才华横溢的助教，他后来去好莱坞写电影剧本，甚至创立了当地版本的“第二城”剧团和一个剧院，你知道的，并且做了一些很棒的事情。但我的意思是，但是关键是，你知道，生物科学，你知道，所有这些。
I mean, even just on sort of a cursory level, get as wide an education as you can. And like I said, it's not just computer science. I mean, one of the things that worries me about computer science these days, and it has for decades now, is when you take a degree in computer science you don't take college physics um yeah that's right you know it's not clear you even take calculus yeah i think well so yeah so basically if i remember correctly i kind of geeked out i took extra courses but yeah i think you're right you you have to take uh right so the way calculus works in universities you take calc one two and three i think for cs but then but then those aren't real calc classes you want to get into a calc or you actually prove all the theorems and that's optional and also just you know i mean i remember when i
我的意思是，甚至只是从粗略的层面来看，尽可能接受广泛的教育。就像我说的，这不仅仅是计算机科学。我的意思是，这些天让我对计算机科学感到担忧的事情之一，而且几十年来一直如此，那就是当你获得计算机科学学位时，你不用上大学物理。嗯，是的，那是真的，你知道的，甚至连微积分你都不一定需要上。嗯，我想，好吧，所以，基本上如果我没记错的话，我有点像个书呆子，我选修了额外的课程，但是是的，我想你是对的，你必须选修，所以微积分在大学里的运作方式是，对于计算机科学，我认为你需要上微积分1、2和3，但是然后，然后那些并不是真正的微积分课程。你想进入那种你实际上要证明所有定理的微积分课程，那是可选的。而且还有，你知道的，我的意思是，我记得当我
took freshman physics you know and suddenly the equation for you you know, where, you know, something's going to fall made sense. You, it was derivatives guys. Yep. Yep. You know, it was all about derivatives, you know, and you know, things just didn't, you know, I think, you know, also I think having a double E degree, I was much more into systems and their dynamics. Right. Right. Whereas I think computer scientists this is what i
上大一物理时，你知道的，突然间关于你，你知道的，某物会下落的方程变得有意义了。你看，那是导数，伙计们。是的。是的。你知道的，这全关于导数，你知道的，而且你知道的，事情就是这样，你知道的，我也认为拥有电子工程学位让我对系统及其动力学更感兴趣。对。对。然而我认为计算机科学家的这个正是我
sort of see in my students is that they're used to everything being linear right yep they're not used to concurrency yeah you don't have to take diff eq uh differential equations or really any of that in cs yep i made the mistake of taking it this summer. Oh, God. Actually, my wife and I were talking about this yesterday. We both took courses in the summer that we just wanted to get over and done with. Neither of us liked history, which now I actually really appreciate history. But as an 18-year-old, I didn't really appreciate history. And so both of us knocked out uh history in the summer uh we took four hours i think four hours a day five days a week of history but we were done in like three months
在我的学生身上看到的，他们习惯了一切都是线性的，对吧，是的，他们不习惯并发，是的，在计算机科学中你不需要学习微分方程，或者实际上不需要任何这些，是的，我犯了今年夏天去学它的错误。哦，天哪。事实上，我和我妻子昨天还在谈论这个。我们俩都在夏天选修了一些我们只想快点应付过去的课程。我们都不喜欢历史，现在我其实真的很感激历史。但作为一个18岁的年轻人，我并不真正感激历史。所以我们俩都在夏天突击学完了历史，我们上了四个小时，我想一天四个小时，一周五天，都是历史课，但我们在大约三个月内就搞定了。
i can't imagine doing diffy q in the summer i took diffy q in the summer that's unbelievable i mean i don't think i would have uh survived that it was we call it the summer of the lost sign yeah i can't imagine right i mean because you know it the summer of the lost sign. Yeah, I can't imagine. Right? I mean, because, you know, it was one of those where you dropped a sign somewhere in the answer. You know, the thing just blew up in your face, right? Yep, yep. And of course, in those days
我无法想象在夏天学微分方程。我就是在夏天学的微分方程，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，我觉得我不可能挺过来。我们管它叫“丢失正负号的夏天”。是的，我无法想象，对吧？我的意思是，因为，你知道的，那是那种你在答案的某个地方丢掉了一个正负号的情况。你知道的，事情直接在你的脸前爆炸了，对吧？是的，是的。当然，在那个年代
we didn't have Math Lab and, you know. Right, right. Well, you know, and I was debating about that today. You really touched on that. I just, I think we mentioned this last time. I just read a book called Faraday Maxwell and the Elect well, first of all, he's the one who translated Maxwell's equations into vector calculus. And he's the one, as a double E, why I had to take a semester course in transmission lines. Oh, interesting. And this guy was really incredible.
我们没有 Matlab，而且，你知道的。对，对。好吧，你知道的，我今天还在讨论这个。你真的触及到了这一点。我只是，我想我们上次提到过这个。我刚刚读了一本名为《法拉第、麦克斯韦与电》的书。首先，他是把麦克斯韦方程组转化为向量微积分的人。正因为他，作为一个电子工程专业的学生，我才必须上一学期的传输线课程。哦，有意思。这个家伙真的很不可思议。
He was, he had had scarlet fever as a child and was deaf or mostly deaf in england telegraph machine operators the telegraph was visual not auditory so he became a telegraph operator okay and taught himself all this stuff and figured out how to find bugs in transmission lines with loading and impedance oh interesting all that stuff right and? And I'm like, wow, now I understand why I had to take a course in transmission lines. Yeah, that makes sense. And then I sort of was, would I
他小时候得过猩红热，在英国时是个聋子或几乎全聋。电报机操作员的电报是视觉的，而不是听觉的，所以他成了一名电报操作员，好吧，并且自学了所有这些东西，琢磨出如何通过加载和阻抗在传输线中找到漏洞。哦，有意思，所有这些，对吧？并且？我心想，哇，现在我明白为什么我必须上一门传输线课程了。是的，这说得通。然后我有点在想，如果
have at 19 or 20 been more interested in it if you told me the history? Like you, I sort of honestly said, probably not. Yep, yep. That's true. It took getting older to really appreciate how they got it figured out. Yeah, totally. Yeah. It's interesting why that, I have to think more about why that phenomena is what it is.
你在我19或20岁时告诉我这段历史，我会对它更感兴趣吗？像你一样，老实说我可能会说，大概不会吧。是的，是的。确实如此。人长大了才会真正欣赏他们是如何弄懂这一切的。是的，完全如此。很有意思，为什么这种现象会是现在这样，我得花更多时间去思考。
But I know a lot of people go through that phase where they start to appreciate history more and more over time um but so i wanted to give you some time also to plug anything you were mentioning a little bit earlier that you have a book uh so what's the what's the name of the book book is called patterns and network architecture patterns and network architecture a return to fundamentals cool it's old in terms of what we know now but i don't think there's anything wrong in it which is scary it's a good sign you know i mean we've confirmed most all of it so far as i know but we've extended it quite a bit and i i need to get to work on a follow-on that brings it up to date but yeah so so there is that out there. And if people want to reach you, what are other ways?
但我知道很多人都会经历这样一个阶段，随着时间的推移，他们开始越来越欣赏历史。嗯，所以我想留点时间让你宣传一下你之前提到过的一点，你有一本书，那么书名叫什么？这本书叫《网络架构模式：回归基础》。很酷。就我们现在所知而言，它有点老了，但我认为它里面没有任何错误，这很可怕。这是个好标志，你知道的，我的意思是，据我所知，我们已经证实了其中的大部分内容，但我们对它进行了相当大的扩展，我需要着手写一本后续著作，将其更新到最新水平。但是，是的，所以这本书就在那里。如果人们想联系你，还有什么其他方式？
Oh, I have a very complicated email. Okay. day at bu.edu. Ah, nice. Oh, that's, yeah, you have actually, we're tied for the shortest email. For a while, I had an email that was the same number of characters. The other one I use, which is the one I probably respond with, is jeanjour at comcast.net. Ah, nice.
哦，我的电子邮件非常复杂。好的。day@bu.edu。啊，真不错。哦，那是个，是的，你实际上，我们的电子邮件长度并列最短。有一段时间，我的电子邮件具有相同数量的字符。我使用的另一个电子邮件，也是我可能会回复的那个，是 jeanjour@comcast.net。啊，真不错。
John Day in French. Nice. Oh, okay. I was trying to guess what it was. Okay, cool. In Gmail, I'm German. So what made you, you just kind of felt like let's do different languages? My name translates in all languages.
法语的 John Day。真不错。哦，好吧。我刚才还在猜它是什么。好吧，酷。在 Gmail 里，我是 German。是什么让你，你只是有一种感觉，让我们用不同的我的名字在所有语言中都能翻译。
Yeah, I guess that's true. Yeah. Very cool. Hey, this was an absolute pleasure. I think I learned a ton. The audience learned a ton. People are going to walk away from this with looking at the Internet in a whole new way. And I hope a lot of folks go out and pick out your book.
好吧，我想这倒也是。是的。太棒了。嘿，这绝对是一种荣幸。我想我学到了很多。听众们学到了很多。人们从这里离开时，会以一种全新的方式看待互联网。我希望很多人能出去买你的书。
We'll link to that in the show notes so that folks can get easy access to that. It's available on Kindle. It's out of print in hard copy. Yeah, I mean, nowadays we definitely promote Kindle. If you want to read it on Kindle, you know highly recommend jumping on amazon getting audible subscription you can do that through the uh programming throwdown link that helps us out as well and uh i think they have it now i i recently got an email where i think there's some kind of synergy between audible and kindle maybe there's a discount like a kickback program or something
我们会在节目文稿中给出链接，以便大家能轻松访问。它在 Kindle 上有售。纸质版已经绝版了。是的，我的意思是，现在我们肯定大力推广 Kindle。如果你想在 Kindle 上阅读，你知道，强烈建议上亚马逊获取 Audible 订阅，你可以通过 Programming Throwdown 的链接来做，这也能帮到我们，而且呃，我想他们现在有了，我最近收到一封电子邮件，说 Audible 和 Kindle 之间似乎有一些协同效应，也许有折扣或回扣计划之类的东西
there but well there's a lot here to dive into and a lot of good thinking. It needs to go on. Yeah, definitely. I mean, if you are, you know, if this is something that super, you know, appeals to you, definitely, you know, take your, you know, architecture course at University Network Architecture. Learn more about it. You know, meet with a lot of those smart people who are going to push you and challenge you, like John mentioned. And yeah, I mean, um yeah i mean there's there's there's you know the internet is not going away that is for sure so the internet is here to stay it's the i believe the internet is like the uh uh you know collective consciousness of humanity
在那里。不过这里有很多东西可以深入探讨，也有很多好的思考需要继续。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，如果你是，你知道的，如果这非常，你知道的，吸引你，绝对地，你知道的，去大学选修你的架构课程——网络架构。了解更多关于它的信息。去结识那些将推动你、挑战你的聪明人，就像约翰提到的一样。是的，我的意思是，嗯，是的，我的意思是，互联网不会消失，那是肯定的。所以互联网会留下来，我相信互联网就像是人类的呃，你知道的集体意识。
and so i don't think it's going anywhere so i i'll tell you i we a whole nother topic but you know i mean all of the stuff that goes on with social media and disinformation and fake news and all this just scares the hell of a Jesus out of me. Yeah, you know, a lot of people don't realize sort of like the communal nature of the Internet. I mean, we haven't had the whole world, you know, influencing each other, you know, in real time before. So this is a whole evolution in humanity but but it's also you look there's there's something about the isolation that allows you to say things or think things you wouldn't if you were in person oh the physical isolation yeah right right you know i mean the well the decoupling, maybe is a better way of putting it.
所以我不认为它会消失，所以，我告诉你，我们，这是一个完全不同的话题，但你知道的，所有与社交媒体、虚假信息、假新闻以及所有这些有关的事情，真的把我吓得半死。是的，你知道的，很多人没有意识到互联网的这种公共性质。我的意思是，我们以前从来没有让全世界在实时中互相影响过。所以这是人类的一次整体进化，但与此同时，你会发现，正是这种隔离感，让你说出了或想出了在面对面时不会说或不会想的话。哦，物理上的隔离，是的，对，对，你知道的，我的意思是，呃，这种解耦，也许是更好的表达方式。
Right, right. You know, the way some of this stuff gets going. And also, I think that, you know, in terms of our world, socially, there were always the strange ones. But they were insulated from each other. Right. And it didn't get out of hand. And now, you know, the most bizarre things get out of hand. Well, yeah, I'm pretty sure that there's state actors involved in a lot of this. So that's a big part of it.
对，对。你知道的，其中一些事情开始发生的方式。而且，我也认为，你知道的，就我们的世界而言，在社会层面上，总有一些奇怪的人。但他们彼此隔离。对。而且它没有失控。而现在，你知道的，最离奇的事情都失控了。嗯，是的，我很确定这里面有很多国家级演员（黑客/水军）参与。所以这是很大一部分原因。
The Internet was much more independent. You know, I feel like now every state actor is saying, oh, how can we get it on this, right? Well, there is that, too. But there's also just the fact that, you know, what people will believe is just amazing. You know, the BS sensor is just not that well-tuned. Yeah, I think we go through cycles in civilization. That's what I'm hoping. Yeah, I think that.
互联网曾经更加独立。你知道的，我觉得现在每个国家级演员都在说：“哦，我们怎么才能分一杯羹呢，对吧？”好吧，这也是有的。但还有这样一个事实，那就是，人们会相信什么，简直令人惊叹。你知道，大家的“胡话雷达”真的没有调得那么准。是的，我认为我们在文明中经历周期。这就是我所希望的。是的，我想是的。
Yeah, I think that, you know, we go through cycles where people I think ultimately I think people are really more afraid. People are more afraid than they've ever been right now. Yeah. I mean, you you could read that historically there was a similar thing with the early days of newspapers, the early days of radio, etc. But I don't know. Maybe it's just us, but this one feels different. Yeah, I mean, I think I see a lot of similarities from the 2020s and the 1920s. But yeah, it's wild.
是的，我认为，你知道的，我们正在经历周期，在这些周期里，人们，我认为最终人们真的更加害怕了。人们比以往任何时候都更加害怕。是的。我的意思是，你可以从历史上读到，早期报纸、早期广播等也曾出现过类似的情况。但我不知道。也许只是我们，但这一次感觉不同。是的，我的意思是，我认为我看到了 2020 年代和 1920 年代有很多相似之处。但是，是的，太疯狂了。
I mean, the only thing we were missing was hyperinflation so uh but anyways well leaving on a good note i think that um um i think that that you know we've had an amazing conversation here um a ton of really good material as i said internet's not going away so if this content interests you, dive deep into networking, network architecture. You're going to learn a lot. As someone who's built, I've built a variety of different networking apps that have various degrees of popularity.
我的意思是，我们唯一缺少的只是恶性通货膨胀，所以，无论如何，带着一个好的音符结束，我认为，呃，嗯，我认为，你知道的，我们在这里进行了一次惊人的对话，大量的优质材料，正如我所说，互联网不会消失，所以如果这个内容让你感兴趣，深入研究网络、网络架构。你会学到很多。作为构建过各种不同流行程度的网络应用程序的人，
I think that there is, as John said, a huge commonality between networking and application development and understanding you know kind of all of that is going to be extremely beneficial um in a society where as the networking uh the internet is not going anywhere so so definitely uh take the time in university to learn about this stuff one of the other points that i always make in my class is that every other aspect of computer science you can go into is a specialization.
我认为，正如约翰所说，网络和应用程序开发之间有着巨大的共性，理解所有这些将在这样一个社会中变得极其有益：随着网络的发展，互联网是不会消失的，所以绝对要花时间在大学里学习这些东西。我在课堂上总是提出的另一个观点是，你可以进入的计算机科学的任何其他方面都是一种专业化。
Networking is the only one that uses all of them. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, you need databases for routing tables. You need everything. Analytics, you need software engineering, you need operating systems, you need it all. Distribution fitting to do all the routing and everything. Yeah, very cool. Well cool well john thank you so
网络是唯一一个运用了所有这些方面的领域。是的，这说得通。是的，我的意思是，路由表需要数据库。你需要一切。分析，你需要软件工程，你需要操作系统，你需要这一切。为了完成所有路由和一切而进行的分布式拟合。是的，非常酷。好吧，酷，约翰，非常感谢
much for coming absolute pleasure i'm really glad that we had the time to do a two-parter because we had so much amazing content and um we'd love to to get feedback from the audience and uh you know if you have questions definitely send them over to john and see you can cc us on the show programming throwdown at gmail and uh again thank you so much for for coming on the show my pleasure take care music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你的到来。绝对是一种荣幸。我真的很高兴我们有时间做一个分两部分的节目，因为我们有如此多惊人的内容，呃，我们很乐意得到听众的反馈，呃，你知道的，如果你有问题，一定要发给约翰，你可以抄送给我们，节目邮箱是 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com，再次非常感谢你来到节目中。不客气，保重。由 Eric Barnard 创作的音乐。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下分发。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但您必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式分享。这个情节还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。